I'M SORRY.
YOU'RE PRESENTING RIGHT. FOR
MUCH CARRIER OF RIGHT. YEAH.
ALRIGHT EVERYONE GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND-
WILL COME TO ORDER- SO GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
ALL NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
IT HERE TO A SOCIAL TESTING
POLICY SOCIAL DISTANCING POLICY
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL HOLD THE CYST
CENTRAL COMMITTEE HEARING HERE
IN THE CAPITAL. WE HAVE MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTINCT SING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCING SERVICES FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE IT WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
OBVIOUSLY ALL ANNOUNCE IT HERE-
RIGHT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPATION
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 I MAY
SAY THAT ONE MORE TIME.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE TO FOUR. ZERO
FOUR NINE ONE I WILL SAY THAT
ONE MORE TIME. THREE TO FOUR
ZERO FOUR NINE ONE ONE WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU IN THEIR
JULIE OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THE
TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK PLEASE TURN OR MUTE
YOUR DEVICE OFF. BUT YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HE- PRIOR TO
GIVING A TESTIMONY BECAUSE WE
HEAR THAT IN THE BACKGROUND IT
MESSES UP YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT
OBVIOUSLY. WE WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON ENCUMBERED BY
BACKGROUND NOISE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND THE BILL
NUMBER TWO WHICH YOU ARE
REFERRING IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
ALSO SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENED
IN THE PAST PEOPLE CALL IN.
THINKING WE'RE ON ONE BILL ONE
RUN ANOTHER PLEASE TRY TO PAY
ATTENTION AND SLEEK AND CALLING
ON THE ACTUAL BILL FOR WHICH
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK- I'LL
TRY TO MAINTAIN. DECORUM AS
BEST AS POSSIBLE- THIS IS A-
SIMPLE HEARING THIS MORNING
WITH JUST THREE- ITEMS BEFORE
US- IT'S ALSO A GOOD TIME TO
REMIND EVERYONE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY. THAT THIS IS A
FISCAL COMMITTEE- WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE RE LITIGATING THE
POLICY MERITS OF THE ITEMS
BEFORE US ARE GONNA BE FOCUSED
ON THE FISCAL. IMPACTS OF THE
BILLS THAT WE ARE HEARING
TESTIMONY SO PLEASE- CONFINE
YOUR COMMENTS TO FISCAL
COMMENTS ONLY. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
OBVIOUSLY SOME LATIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF THIS ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY TOOL SO I ASK
EVERYONE TO BE PATIENT HAS WE
GO THROUGH. THE HEARING TODAY.
BY WILL BE HEARING THREE BILLS
AND ALL OF THEM ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR A DO PASS MOTION- TWO OF
THEM ARE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WHICH MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
THIS EEK. IN ORDER TO APPEAR
ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT AND A
THIRD MEASURE IS SUBJECT TO THE
DEADLINES OF THIS WEEK'S
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR AS WELL
WHICH IS WHY. THIS SPECIAL
HEARING WAS NECESSITATED. WE A
FULL COMMITTEE HEARING WITH US
TODAY AND SO I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR SHOWING UP. ON
THE SHORT NOTICE FOR THE
SPECIAL HEARING. SO LET'S
ESTABLISH REFORM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GOOD
CENTER PORTANTINO WAY I'M HERE.
HERE BATES HERE BATES HERE
BRADFORD ERA BRADFORD HERE HILL
HERE HILL HERE JONES. JONES
HERE LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE MY
COUNTY HERE. MY COUNTY HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM FOR. WE HAVE A
QUORUM- DUE TO THE- TECHNOLOGY
RESTRAINTS OF THE HEARING AND
THE CONSIDERATION OF OUR
CALENDAR WE'RE GOING TO BE
LIMITING BOTH PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS. PRIMARY OPPONENTS
AND OPPONENTS TO A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES PER SIDE WERE
ALSO- ANY FOLLOW UP COMMENTS
WILL BE LIMITED TO NAME. A
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
OUR FIRST ITEM. ON OUR AGENDA
WHICH IS SB FOURTEEN TEN
AUTHORED BY SENATORS CABBIE ARE
OLD AND BRADFORD. ON EMERGENCY
TENNESSEE'S A MISTER BRADFORD
IS GOING TO BE PRESENTING SB
FOURTEEN TEN MISTER BRADFORD
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT SB
FOURTEEN TEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
CAFIERO I'M HONORED TO PRESENT
AS FEE FOURTEEN TEN A MEASURE
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THROUGH THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST TWO AND
A HALF MONTHS AND WE FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON TENANT LANDLORD
BECAUSE THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF
THE LARGEST ISSUES THAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED- THE FEAR OF THE
OBJECTION. AND LOSS OF INCOME
BY OWNERS WE KNOW THE IMPACTS
THAT CO AT NINETEEN IS HERE ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ECONOMICALLY A EVEN BEFORE THIS
CRISIS NEARLY SIX MILLION
RESIDENTS- WE ARE ALSO RUNNING
HOUSEHOLDS WERE ARE HAVING
TROUBLE MAKING RENT THAT IS
ONLY EXACERBATED SINCE COVERT
NINETEEN AND WE ALSO KNOW THE
CHALLENGES THAT. LANDLORDS WERE
FACING ALSO WHEN THEY WEREN'T
RECEIVING RENT ON TIME- PUTTING
THEM IN JEOPARDY OF FORECLOSURE
THIS MEASURE TRIES TO ADDRESS.
BOTH MEASURES THE VOTE AVOIDING
OF- EVICTIONS AND ALSO WITH A
WARNING OF FORECLOSURES WE'VE
TRIED TO- DO IT IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY SP FOURTEEN TEN
IS THE RIGHT RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS BECAUSE- IT BALANCES THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. AND HOMES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
THE BUDGETARY OUR RESOURCES ARE
LIMITED SO WE DO NOT WANT TO
APPEAR- FUNDING- BUT CENTRAL
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS ANY KIND
OF WAY. BUT WE ALSO DO NOT WANT
TO PUSH VULNERABLE PEOPLE ONTO
THE STREETS. OR INTO
FORECLOSURE AS AYE OWNER SB
FOURTEEN CAN RESPONSE THE
CHALLENGES BY KEEPING PEOPLE
HOUSE. AND DELAYING SIGNIFICANT
STATE EXPENSES BY SEVERAL
FISCAL YEARS. THIS IS POSSIBLE
BY USING. TAX CREDITS SO
LANDLORDS CAN EITHER KEEP OR
THEY CAN SELL THIS PROGRAM
PARTIALLY FINDS ITSELF BY
STARTING CAN IT PAYMENTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. WHEN THE
LANDLORD TAX CREDITS MATURE.
PROGRAM IS NOT FREE WE ALL KNOW
THAT. DON AND YET IT'S MORE
BALANCE THAN SOME ALTERNATIVES
THAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR A NOBODY
GETS A FREE RIDE NOT THE TENANT
NOR THE LANDLORD TENANT STILL
HAVE TO REPAY THEIR LAND. BACK
TO THE STATE STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- THERE WILL BE
HARDSHIP EXEMPTIONS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO QUALIFY MYLAR
TWENTY ON WILL NOT GET A FREE
RIDE ALSO THIS PROGRAM. COULD
GO A LONG WAY IN KEEPING SMALL
LANDLORDS SOLVENT- BOTH CENTER
COMMON ERROR WHEN I. ARE CLEAR
ABOUT THE DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
BILL WILL CONTINUE AS IT MOVES
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BRADFORD ARE THERE. OPPONENTS
OF THE ESPY FOURTEEN TEN HERE
TIME SPEAK. OLD. THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE CHAMBER. IS THERE ANYONE
IN. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN I DO NOT
BELIEVE SO. AND SUPPORT SEEING
NO ONE HERE IN THE CHAMBER OR
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. WHAT.
TELECONFERENCE I'M SORRY JERRY
ONE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FOUR ONE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ALL. AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER AND THEN PLACE YOU
BACKING Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. FOUR SB
FOURTEEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT TO DETERMINE. LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JIM BEAR- UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO CALLING IN
STRONG WORK FOR EIGHTY FIVE.
AND EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR SB FOURTEEN TEN.
IS THERE ANY IS THERE ANOTHER
ONE COMING UP OR- YES IT IS.
IT'S ONE IF PEOPLE ONLINE
COULD- WE ARE ON SB FOURTEEN
TEN WE ARE NOT ON A SEE A FIVE
OR A CA SIX YET SO THIS IS
TESTIMONY FOR. SB FOURTEEN TEN
SO PLEASE LOG ON ACCORDINGLY-
AND PAY ATTENTION TO THE THREE
DIFFERENT AND DISTINCT ITEMS
BEFORE US AND TRY TO MAKE YOUR
COMMENTARY ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE ACTUAL MEASURE SHOW AGAIN
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TEN. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF THROUGH THE MODERATOR
ONLINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
IF YOU ARE NOT CALLING FOR SB
FOURTEEN TEN BEFORE ANOTHER ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO ZERO TO
REMOVE YOURSELF. IF YOU ARE NOT
WANTED TO SPEAK ON SB ONE FOUR
ONE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
THEIR- TO REMOVE YOURSELF AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN ONE MOMENT THERE. A
LINE NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND THE TERM AND WE
ON TO THE NEXT ONE LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN LINE I OPEN FOR SB
FOURTEEN TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NUMBER ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS A MARA
WILSON CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
AB AT LOS ANGELES. AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE FOUR
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU AND OUR
NEXT LINE COMES FROM THE LINE
ONE ONE FOUR LINE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN LINE ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY ONE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
ARE TO LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE ONE SIX FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD NO. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
DEMOCRATIC TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WHILE WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
BECAUSE OF THE SPEED AT WHICH
THE- BILL WAS AMENDED WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHORS- FOR THEIR
FOCUS ON THE NEED FOR
ASSISTANCE. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM
TO FIND A BALANCE FOR SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN IT WAS WHAT YOU
GOT AS THE. I'M SORRY MY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD ARGUE THAT THERE A
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ALSO
ANNOUNCE HOW PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE WRONG BILL
CAN WITHDRAW THEMSELVES FROM
THE QUEUE SO THEY CAN GET BACK
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE NEXT BILL.
YOU COULD WALK THEM THROUGH
THAT AS WELL. YES THERE IF YOU
ARE NOT ONLINE FOR SB ONE FOUR
ONE ZERO PLEASE PLATE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF I WANTED TIME FOR YOUR
BILL YOU WILL PRESS ONE THEN
THEIR OLD TO JOIN THE- QUEUE
AGAIN. SO IF YOU ARE CALLING
NOW FOR SB ONE FOUR ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO. IF YOU ARE NOT
CALLING TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
ONE FOUR ONE ZERO AT THE
MOMENT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE OUGHT TO REMOVE YOURSELF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IN
LINE FORTY FOUR THE LINE IS
OPEN FOR SB FOURTEEN TEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
MAUREEN FINANCE ON A TENANT IN
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA MY SENATOR
AND SENATOR FRAZIER I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BRADFORD AND
CAREER- FOR THIS BILL UNLIKE
MANY NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
KOBE NINETEEN AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SHOW MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR.
AT E. FOR TEN THANK YOU SB
FOURTEEN TED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND LINE NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR SB
FOURTEEN TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE THREE
THREE. WHY ONE THIRTY THREE.
YOU COULD JUST OFF ON ME TO GET
MY ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE FIVE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FOR SB FOURTEEN TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SOCIAL
MODEL THAT WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS THE CALLING ON BEHALF.
HELLO AND CALIFORNIAN BE IN
COURT- AS WELL AS ON AND HUGE
AND ASK TO BE AT HOME- YOU HAVE
THE SUPPORT IN CONTACT ADDITION
AGL. THANK YOU AND LINE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD FOR SB
FOURTEEN TEN. LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR SB
FOURTEEN TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS SERRA- AS THE
LANDLORD I STRONGLY STRONGLY
POSTED WITH GARLIC PATH CREDIT
MAN LAW MEET CASH TO PAY THE
MORTGAGE FAIL SHE PAID THE
CONCRETE CáC. ALL MAY BE
MAKING IT MAY NEED INCOME TO
KEEP THEM ALIVE AND WELL THANK
YOU CAME IN OPPOSITION IS NEXT
YOU HAVE TO Q. BACK UP FOR
OPPOSITION FROM THOUGH SHE'S.
HE HAD OUR OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WELL I NUMBER
ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE. LINE ONE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD I WOULD. OR DIFFERENT
BILL. OKAY OUT LOOKING BACK UP
WHEN THAT TIME ONE MOMENT. LINE
ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN PLAN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I WANT IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN MY ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR SB
FOURTEEN TEN IN SUPPORT OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT. THE TERM AND THAT IS OUR
LAST PERSON IN Q. THANK YOU I'M
A MODERATOR- FOR ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBER WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
FOURTEEN TEN. SAYING NO ONE
HERE IS THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
FOURTEEN TEN. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE COMING TO SPEAK ON
FOURTEEN TEN MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE AND AGAIN
FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE ONLINE.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITION PORTION
TO SB FOURTEEN TEN NOT A SEE A
FIVE OR A CA SIX. SO PLEASE
ONLY BE IN THE QUEUE IF YOU ARE
A HOPING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FOURTEEN TEN THOSE OTHER
TWO MEASURES WILL COME LATER.
SO LET'S DO FOURTEEN TEN IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
FOURTEEN TEN ONLINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN
NOW. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEY DID THEIR OWN NOW. MISTER
CHAIRMAN LINE ONE ZERO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING. YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU SIR.
WELL I'M A LANDLORD AND ALSO
TENANTS. I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION BOTH SB WASHINGTON.
THANK YOU AND LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
YEAH PONDERED NUMBER AND I
REALLY WANT YOU WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT THE FOURTEEN AND
ARE YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT A
LOT OF LANDLORDS ONE I DON'T
HAVE ONE OKAY TO- PROMPTING TO
REALLY RELIED ON TO MAKE AB I
STRONG STRONG FULL SB FORTY AND
THE DIRTY DON'T HAVE ANY CASH
FLOW FOR THE FOUR YEAR HOW DO
MAKING THE LINE. PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY
MORTGAGE BE OUR PARTY PACKAGE
MAKING THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE
ILLEGAL ACTOR CLOUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE ONCE. ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND LINE
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS LINE ONE
ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS
GEORGE FROM ORANGE COUNTY AS A
HOMEOWNER I STRONGLY OPPOSED BY
ONE OR- BUT YOU CAN. THANK YOU
AND ONE ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M A HOMEOWNER
HELLO EVERYONE I'M HOME OUR
LETTER OF THEIR- BAY AREA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE FOURTEEN
TEN THANK. THANK YOU AND ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT QUITE
FROM THE FROM OKAY MIND- ONLY
OUR VISION OF THE AT THE
FOURTEEN TEN BECAUSE THE
LANDLORD ALSO NEED- HATE THAT
FIELD AND THE MARKET. AND THEN
YOU'D THE NEED AND EVEN BASED
ON BOTH- RENTAL INCOME AS WELL-%
I'M STRONGLY AGAINST THE SB
FOURTEEN K. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND LINE ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE ONE SIX TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME.
MY NAME IS CHANGE HAS AND I'M
FROM SAN JOSE- I SHANIA OPPOSE.
AT THREE ONE FOUR TEN. BECAUSE
LANDLORDS ALSO NEED TO MAKE A
LEGAL DESPAIR AT THIS POINT IN
THE TESTIMONY OF FOLKS ONLINE
COULD JUST KEEP THEIR COMMENTS
TO THEIR NAME. OUR ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
LIME ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF YOU SHARE SENATORS
FEEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION. OUR RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN TEN OF THE
PROVIDER FOR HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE DEEPLY IN
THAT THEN THIS PRESSING ISSUE
FOR ALL I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORKING WITH
VENDORS CABALLERO. SENATOR
BRADFORD REPRESENTING THANK YOU
WONDERFUL CITY OF COMPTON.
THANK YOU AND LINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LAYING SO FROM
THE **** CITY I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN TEN. THE
TERM AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU- MATTER
MODERATOR MISTER WHITE CASKEY
WOULD LIKE TO. WAIT A NICE HERE
HAND UP. YES MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
OVER THE ON THE BILL. IF WE'RE
DONE WITH THE PUBLIC HEARING WE
ARE BRINGING IT BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS THANK YOU. CENTER
BRADFORD THE THIS GRAHAM ONLY
COVERS UNPAID RENT THAT'S A
CRUDE UP TO THE ENDING OF THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY THE CURRENT
STATE OF EMERGENCY THERE ARE
SOME WHO ARE CONCERNED THAT. WE
MAY. CALL ALL CLEAR AND THEN
FIND OUT THAT THE PANDEMIC
ACTUALLY USING IT CONTINUE SIR
UP OCCUR ARE SIR ANY CONDUCT.
CONTINGENCY FOR- BY I GUESS THE
REOCCUR ARE A RE STATE
REINSTATEMENT OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WITH THE SAME
PANDEMIC THAT WE'RE FACING NOW.
AND THAT'S A GREAT CONCERN THAT
HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP AS RELATES
NOT ONLY TO HOUSING BUT THE
HEALTH CARE AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT WE'RE FACING HERE IF.
THERE'S A RECURRENCE THIS BILL
DOES NOT HAVE A RESET BUT IT
LOOKS AT THE CONTINUING ONGOING
CRISIS SO YOU HAVE SIX MONTHS
FROM THE TIME. OF THE CRISIS
STARTED TO WAVER RANT AND IF IT
IS EXTENDED ON BE BEYOND THAT
POINT- THE TENANT CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AGAIN. OKAY
IN IN THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
MISTER CHAIR IS THAT WE HAVE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT'S NOT
GOING TO ALLOW ANY UNLAWFUL
DETAINER HEARINGS HERE. WE'VE
GOT THIS THE- THE CRISIS THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY ENDING- IF
THE PARTIES AGREE BECAUSE THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM I HEARD
A LOT OF UP OPPOSITION BUT THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. IF THE
PARTIES AGREE AND WE HAVE WE'RE
A LITTLE BIT OVER IN THE WITH
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY ENDED
BUT THEY'VE AGREED THAT THEY'LL
TAKE THE RENT. IS THERE A
CONDITION THAT THIS FRANCHISE-TAX BOARD WILL ALLOW THAT
VOLUNTARY REPAYMENT PERIOD TO
GO ONE IT'S STILL WITHIN THE
SIX MONTH PERIOD BUT IT SAID.
THAT HARD STOP AT THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND THAT'S WHAT- THE
BILL STATES RIGHT NOW WE'RE
NEGOTIATIONS THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO SEE WHAT ROLE THEY'RE
WILLING TO PLAY. AN EXTENDING
THAT PERIOD BUT YES WE LOOKED
AT THOSE PROVISIONS AND IS
MEASURE TO INVOLVED- FRENCH I
SELF FOR TO EXIST. WITH THIS
PROCESS THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION MISTER CHAIR AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS I SEE MISS BATES
FOR THEIR HAND UP GO AHEAD. I
TALK ON THE- MMHM IF IT ON THE
MICROPHONE YEAH. IT IS THERE'S
A THE BILL HAS A BLANK AND IT
IS REYES LIT UP THE MICROPHONE
YOU GO CAN HEAR ME YEP. THE
BILL HAS A BLANK IN IT IT'S A
CRITICAL PIECE OF INFORMATION
MISSING WHICH IS THE NUMBER OF
DAYS WILL FOR WHICH RAN COULD
BE DEFERRED SO THERE'S NO WAY
TO TELL HOW MUCH RENT WOULD BE
DEFERRED AND HOW MUCH THE TAX
CREDITS WOULD COST THE STATE. I
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY THAT EXISTS IN THE IN THE
BILL. IN EUROPE WHICH IS. WHICH
REFERENCE I CAN HEAR WHAT WOULD
YOU REPEAT THE QUESTION. WELL
YOU DIDN'T HEAR IT SORRY OF.
THERE'S A BLANK IN THE BILL. A
BLANK WHICH OF DOESN'T TELL THE
NUMBER OF DAYS FOR WHICH RANT
CAN BE DEFERRED IN AT FAULT
WITHOUT THAT INFORMATION
THERE'S NO WAY TO TELL HOW MUCH
RENT WOULD BE DEFERRED HOW MUCH
RENT WOULD BE DEFERRED AND HOW
MUCH THE TAX CREDITS WOULD COST
THE STATE THE OF REFERENCE IN
THE BILL I JUST HAVE IT ON MY
DIGEST HERE BUT IT THAT
SPECIFICALLY COMES UNDER.
PROHIBITION OF UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTIONS IT PROVIDE
PROHIBITS ANY DEMAND FOR UNPAID
RENT ACCRUED DURING THE COLD AT
NINETEEN STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
BLANK DAYS THEREAFTER EXCEPT AS
SPECIFIED ARM FURTHER PROHIBITS
ANY NOTICE TERMINATING TENDENCY
INCLUDING FOR THOSE AGAINST
MOBILE HOME PARK TENNIS FOR
UNPAID RANCH THAT ACCRUED AND
CONDUCT THAT OCCURRED DURING
THE- BOB. STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND BLANK DAYS THEREAFTER I'M
ASSUMING THAT MIGHT HAVE TO DO
WITH. HOW LONG THE EMERGENCY.
EXISTS BUT TO HAVE IT OPEN IN
THE BILL THE QUESTION IS THAT
GOING TO BE PART OF. AN
AGREEMENT THAT THE TENANT AND
THE OWNER SIGN THAT OWNER
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT WOULD
ONLY BE FILLED IN WHEN YOU HAVE
THE ANSWER. OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT COULDN'T BE
AFFECTED. BOB PRIOR TO US
HAVING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
ARE TERMINATED. I THINK IT'S
VERY CONFUSING. ALL I THINK IT
MAINTENANCE TO THE QUESTION
THAT ARE SENATOR FROM FREMONT
WAS ASKING BECAUSE THERE'S AN
EXTENSION OF THIS CRISIS WE
BELIEVE THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE LANDLORD AND THE TENANT TO
NEGOTIATE IN EXTEND. BEYOND
LET'S SAY A SET SIX MONTHS
PERIOD AGAIN. THIS BILL IS
RETROACTIVE TO THE POINT OF
WHEN THE CRISIS STARTED IF I
RUNNER HAS HAD A HARDSHIP AND
YES AND IF IT EXTENDS BEYOND
THAT SIX MONTHS IT LEAVES THE
FLEXIBILITY TO EXTEND THE
PROGRAM. BEYOND THAT POINT. BUT
AS FAR AS THE HEART COST OF
THAT. I CAN'T ANSWER THAT RIGHT
NOW THAT'S PART OF THE ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS ARE WHAT THIS WILL
COST BUT WE'VE ESTIMATED- A FEW
HUNDRED- I THINK IT'S- ABOUT.
ROUGHLY FEW MILLION- THE FIRST
YEAR STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES HAD A QUESTION AS WELL
YES WELL I WAS JUST ONE MORE I
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF THE
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT EVICTIONS.
PROHIBITIVE ACTIONS ON REQUEST
FOR PAYMENT OF OVERDUE RANT FOR
ALL LANDLORDS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY PARTICIPATED IN IN THE
AGREEMENT. I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
PROBABLY A WORK IN PROGRESS OF
SOME OF THESE MIGHT BE. YOU
KNOW TIGHTENED UP BUT THAT I
THINK THAT'S ANOTHER. QUESTION
ALL PART OF THE BILL THAT'S NOT
CLEARLY DEFINED THE OBVIOUSLY
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
CREATE A THIRD PARTY VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT. ARE THE STATE AND
THE TENANT- AND YOU HAVE TO OPT
INTO THE PROGRAM SO. MISTER
BRADFORD- OBVIOUSLY IF THERE IS
A DRAFTING. ERROR THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PACKAGE- AND SO THE
QUESTIONS ARE DULY NOTED IN
WILL BE- EVALUATED TO SEE IF
IT'S A- DRAFTING ENSURE CLARITY
ISSUE. AND IF I CAN SPEAK TO
THE VICTIM PART THIS IS NOT
PREVENT A LANDLORD FROM
EXERCISING TRADITIONAL.
EVICTION PROCESS IF. THE
SITUATION WARRANTS THAT TO THAT
DOESN'T PREVENT THAT AND IT
DOESN'T INVOLVE ANY LANDLORD
WHO IS NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM AT ALL SO THEY CAN
STILL CARRY OUT THEIR TYPICAL
UNLAWFUL DETAINER INFECTION
NOTICES AS- IF THIS BILL DIDN'T
EXIST FOR THOSE THEY'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM.
ALL RIGHT MISTER JONES HAD A
QUESTION YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT-
I'M FOLLOWING UP ON SENATOR
BATES QUESTION THAT I SEE SOME
MEMBERS TRYING TO FIND THOSE
BLANK LINES THESE THEY START ON
PAGE FIVE. OF THE TEXT OF THE
BILL THAT WAS ALSO ONE OF MY
CONCERNS- AND I YOU KNOW. I
THINK ONE OF THE COMMENTS MADE
WAS. IN ANSWERING CENTER BATES
QUESTIONS WE DON'T KNOW YET.
HOW MUCH TIS IS GOING TO COST.
I WOULD REMIND ALL OF US ON
THIS COMMITTEE THAT THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO KNOW HOW MUCH BILLS
COST. BEFORE THEY LEAVE THIS
COMMITTEE. AND GO TO THE FLOOR
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S A GOOD
REASON TO HOLD THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE FOR RIGHT NOW- I DO
WANT TO. COMPLEMENT THE- THE
AUTHORS OF THE BILL. YOU KNOW
THIS IS A PRETTY SIMPLE
PROBLEM. OF FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE A HARD TIME PAYING RENT-
BECAUSE OF THE CO BID. AND THE
GOVERNMENT- REQUIRE SHUT DOWN
OF OUR ECONOMY. AND THIS IS A
VERY CREATIVE. WAY TO SOLVE A
VERY SIMPLE PROBLEM THE PROBLEM
WITH THE WITH THE VERY CREATIVE
SOLUTION IS A LOT OF HOLES IN
IT AS HAS ALREADY BEEN POINTED
OUT- BY OUR GOOD CALLING FROM
ORANGE COUNTY BUT YOU KNOW THE
SOME OTHER CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
ABOUT THE BILL IS. IT ALLOWS
FOR THE FEDERAL TAX BOARD- TO
BURKE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO
READ READ RECEIVE INTEREST IF
THE LANDLORD OWES THEM MONEY.
BUT THE LANDLORD IS NOT
RECEIVING INTEREST IF THE
LANDLORD IS OWED MONEY. ANOTHER
PROBLEM THAT I SEE WITH THE
BILL THAT I THINK SHOULD
CONCERN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
ON THE COMMITTEE HERE IS WE ARE
OBLIGATING FUTURE
LEGISLATURE'S- TO ACT ON ON
THIS BILL- IN APPROPRIATIONS.
AND ONE OF THE ASPECTS OF THE
BILL IS UPON APPROACH
APPROPRIATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE CREDIT MAY BE
REFUNDED. SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF WE APPROVE THIS
TODAY AND WE'RE OBLIGATING
FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S IN THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR BEYOND.
AND THEY JUST DECIDE YOU KNOW
WHAT WE DON'T CARE WHAT
HAPPENED IN TWENTY TWENTY. I
HAVE FOR THOSE LEGISLATORS ARE
GONE. OR FOR WHATEVER VARIOUS
REASONS- WE'RE JUST NOT GONNA
APPROPRIATED. SO HOW HOW ARE WE
GIVING. CONFIDENCE TO THE
LANDLORDS OR EVEN THE-
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THAT THE
DOES APPROPRIATIONS ARE GOING
TO TAKE PLACE- IN THE FUTURE.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS KIND OF
INTERESTING TO ME IS IT IN ALL
THE ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL REALLY DO SOUND GOOD
AT ALL MEANT THAT- IN THE IN
THE THIRD PARTY AGREEMENT AND
ALL OF THAT. THIS A PROPOSITION
IS ONLY FOR THE LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN IT. BUT THE BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT EVICTIONS OR
REQUEST FOR PAYMENT OF OVERDUE
RENT FOR ALL LANDLORDS. WHETHER
OR NOT THEY PARTICIPATE IN THE
DEFERRED GRANT PROGRAM SO I'LL
JUST CONCLUDE WITH THIS MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DO APPRECIATE THE
CREATIVITY- AND OF COURSE OF
THE AUTHOR WANTS TO RESPOND
THOSE. YOU KNOW I'M I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN TO. RESPONSES TO
THOSE CONCERNS- I JUST DON'T
THINK IT'S IN THE OKAY IN THE
VERNACULAR OF THE LEGISLATURE
FULLY COOKED AND I THINK WE
NEED TO HOLD IN COMMITTEE AND
FILL IN THOSE BLANK LINES AND
TRY TO SOLVE THESE OTHER
PROBLEMS BEFORE WE MOVE IT TO
THE FLOOR AND THEN. AND THEN
DELIVER A ANON FINISHED
PRODUCTS TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
HOPE THAT THEY GET IT RIGHT SO
LET'S HOLD IT HERE IN AND FIX
IT BEFORE WE SEND IT ON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. WHICH
BRADFORD- DO YOU WANT TO ANSWER
THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES I HAVE A
COUPLE COMIC. SO I MAKE MY
COMMENTS AND THEN IF YOU COULD
DO YOUR CLOTHES I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER HANDS GO UP- SO I CAN
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. THE GOAL OF THE
WORKING GROUP. THAT'S BEEN
WORKING TO HELP WITH ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FROM THE COVE IT DEBT
CRISIS. IS TO STABILIZE THE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKET- AND THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM TO DO
THAT- NO ONE IS GOING TO BE
FORCED TO OPT IN- BUT WE'VE
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM BOTH
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS. THAT
THERE HAVE TO BE POLICIES THAT
ARE FAIR TO BOTH- THERE'S A MIS
UNDERSTANDING OF SOME PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT. YOU KNOW EVERY
LANDLORD IS PART OF A MAJOR.
LANDLORDS THERE'S A LOT OF
WORKING PEOPLE WHO WHO BOUGHT A
SECOND RENTAL INCOME AS A WAY
TO OFFSET THEIR LACK OF A
PENSION OR THEIR LACK OF A
RETIREMENT. AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF MOM AND POP LANDLORDS
OUT THERE. WHO NEED STABILITY
AS WELL AS THE TENANTS WHO NEED
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AND SO THE
IDEA WAS TO COME UP WITH A
THREE PARTY AGREEMENT THAT
WOULD NOT AFFECT. THE GENERAL
FUND OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTION THE BALANCED
BUDGET AND SO THIS WAS THAT
PROPOSAL TO SHOULD BRING
STABILITY. AND FAIRNESS TO THE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKET AND IT'S
TOO IMPORTANT OF A TASK. TO NOT
HAVE THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH
THE PROCESS- OBVIOUSLY GIVEN
ARE TRUNCATED SCHEDULE THERE
ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT. BUT I DON'T THINK
WE CAN. JUST TURN OUR BACK TO
THAT NEED TO STABILIZE THE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKET BECAUSE
OF THIS PARTICULAR SNAPSHOT IN
TIME. THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE ON THIS PROPOSAL SO.
OBVIOUSLY THE CHAIR IS GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING MOVING THIS
PROPOSAL OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
ON TO THE FLOOR. SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HASTE.
BECAUSE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
MARKET PLACE STABILITY IS THAT
GREAT SO WITH THAT MISTER
MISTER BRADFORD YOU WANNA MAKE
A CLOSE. IF I WAS SMART ALLOW
YOU TO ME YOUR COMMENTS TO BE
MY CLOTHES BUT I WILL. RESPOND
TO A FEW THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED. YES THERE ARE SOME.
GRAY AREAS STEEL BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO WORK THIS THING OUT AS I
STATED IN MY- OPENING COMMENTS
PROBABLY. THE MOST DISCUSSED
THE ISSUE DURING THIS CALL THE
CRISIS IS LANDLORD TENANT
RELATIONSHIPS. AND THE FEAR OF
EVICTION BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE FEAR OF LANDLORDS NOT BEING
TO MAKE MORTGAGE PAYMENTS AND
WE TOOK ALL THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE- TRY TO
CRAFT A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT LOOKS OUT AFTER BOTH SOME
FOLKS. EARLY ON THE DISCUSSION
FELT WE WERE TOO HEAVY ON THE
TENANT SIDE AND THEN AT THE
SAME TIME AS OUR CHAIRMAN
STATED. WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
LANDLORDS AS BECAUSE THESE ARE
NOT ALL MAJOR CORPORATIONS USER
MOM AD POP OPERATORS SOME
FOLKS RURAL OWNER OCCUPIED HAVE
A TRI PLEX THE LIVE IN ONE UNIT
IN AB TWO UNITS AVAILABLE. AND
THEY'RE RUNNING OUT AND AGAIN
AS STATED IT'S THEIR RETIREMENT
IT'S YOUR COLLEGE FUND FOR
THEIR KIDS OR THEIR GRANDKIDS.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED SO. THIS IS
WHAT THIS MEANT A MEASURES
TRYING TO DO IS TRYING TO
THREAD. THE NEEDLE THE BLANK
AREA IS TO LEAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
ON GOING. DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
CRISIS BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S STILL
MOVING JUST WHEN WE THINK IT IS
SKYLIGHTS SUCCEEDED WE SEE NOW
THERE IS X. INCREASING SPREAD
INTO A LOT OTHER STATES SO WE
WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS AND NOT
JUST PUT. A HARD NUMBER ARE
DATE STOP ON THIS MEASURE SO WE
WANT TO HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
THAT IF. THIS CRISIS CONTINUES
ON WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY- I THINK THE
COMMITTEE THE STAFF HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB TO ESTIMATE YES THIS
WILL COST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE NEXT TEN. YEARS
POSSIBLY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME. IT'S A LOOSE NUMBER
BECAUSE THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM. AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY FOLKS WILL PARTICIPATE I
MEAN IN THE BEST. CASE SCENARIO
WE WOULD HOLD NO ONE WOULD HAVE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
BUT IF. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
CHOOSE TO AGAIN THAT LANDLORD
AND TENANT. YOU KNOW CHOOSE THE-
DISSIPATED AND WE'VE WE'VE- WE
HAVE TO FACTOR THAT IN BUT NOT
TO HAVE A PART NUMBER I MEAN.
WILL PARTICIPATE IT'SHARD TO
GIVE YOU A HARD NUMBER TODAY-
IN WHAT IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE
SO I UNDERSTAND THOSE CONCERNED
BUT AGAIN- THIS IS GOING TO BE
REFLECTIVE ON HOW MANY FOLKS
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM. I
THINK THE COMMITTEE AGAIN STAFF
HAS DONE A GREAT JOB AT THAT
ESTIMATION A WHAT THAT COST
COULD BE BUT IT COULD BE A
WHOLE LOT LAS PHIL- AND- WE'RE
AGAIN JUST TRYING TO RESPOND SO
YOU. AS I STATED YESTERDAY IN A
PERFECT WORLD WE WOULD HOPE WE
WOULD HAVE TO USE. THIS MEASURE
BUT OUT WE MUST KEEP FOLKS FROM
LOSING THEIR HOMES AS WELL AS-
INDIVIDUALS GOING INTO
FORECLOSURE AND THIS MEASURE
RESPONSE TO THAT. CALL OF
ACTION WE'RE JUST RYING TO BE
RESPONSE. RESPONSIBLE AND
RESPONSIVE TO THOSE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE SO TODAY-
BY LEVERAGING THE POWER OF THE
STATE- BALANCE SHEET THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND I
CENTER COPIER ON I OUR
CONTINUED. WILL COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS BILL
AND DISCUSS ANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
TODAY AS IT MOVES TOWARD
STARSTRUCK LAST YEAR I VOTE.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY MISTER WHITE KOWSKI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE BECAUSE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FOURTEEN TEN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. HI THERE PORTANTINO
ALL HIGH BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. BRENT BY. I HILL I
JONES. NOW THAT JONES NO LEYVA
I. LEYVA I AYE CASKEY HI. MY
CAL SKI. OF THIS FIVE TO SEE.
THE BILL OUT FIVE TWO MISTER
BRAD FOR THANK YOU FOR PRESENTE
IT OBVIOUS THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE BUT IT'S AN AND- IS. SO IT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING ON A
CA FIVE I SEE ME WEBER AND THE
BACK. AGAIN FOR FOLKS ONLINE WE
ARE MOVING TO A SEE A FIVE NOT
A SEE A SIX- ALSO. FOR FOLKS
ONLINE THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION WILL BE TO DO
PASSED TO THE SENATE FOR. SO
THAT SHOULD GIVE YOU AN
INDICATION- OBVIOUSLY WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S PUBLIC
COMMENT. BUT TAKE THAT AS AN
INDICATION. ALSO WHICH WEBER IS
HERE IN PERSON WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING- THIS MEASURE. I
ALSO WANT TO- SHARE WITH FOLKS
AGAIN THIS IS THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT GOING TO RE
LITIGATE. THE POLICY REALLY
TALK ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACTS.
AND SO WITH THAT- IS WEBER
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT ACA FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT TO YOU A CA FIVE. A
MEASURE THAT WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO REVISIT
AND EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS ABOUT
REMEDIES FOR GENDER BIAS AND
DISPARITY. WITH THE CHOICE OF
REMOVING CALIFORNIA'S
REGRESSIVE BAN ON GENDER
CONSCIOUS AND RACE CONSCIOUS
PRACTICES. ACA FIVE SEEKS TO
PREVENT CONTINUED
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR BY ALLOWING
GENDER. RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DIVERSITY BE CONSIDERED AS ONE
OF MANY FACTORS IN PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. PUBLIC CONTRACTING
IN PUBLIC EDUCTION. THE COSTS
ARE MINIMAL TO THE STATE CENSUS
MEASURES SIMPLY PUTS THE
QUESTION OUT TO THE VOTERS
AFTER TWENTY FOUR YEARS. AND
DOES NOT MANDATE OR REQUIRE
STATE AGENCIES TO BEGIN. EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS. IN A MEMO
TO ATTACK GENERAL OF. UNLIKELY
OR THE TO SO ANALYST'S NO THAT
THERE WERE THEY WOULD NOT A OF
ANY SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS TO
THE STATE AS A RESULT OF THE
PASSAGE OF PROP. IS PROPOSITION
TWO OH NINE. HOWEVER A TWENTY
FIFTEEN STUDY DEMONSTRATES THAT
WOMEN AND MINORITIES OWN
BUSINESSES LOSE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
CONTRACTS DUE TO THE PASSAGE OF
TWO OH NINE. REMOVING THE BAN
ON EQUAL OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND DECREASE
HEALTH INEQUITIES IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND COULD
HAVE ITS POTENTIAL POSITIVE
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL IMPACT FOR
WOMEN. AND PEOPLE OF COLOR HERE
WOULD HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON THE
PHONE OF IT OF AS- CHARLESTON'S
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAPPENING
ASSOCIATION. AND JOHN'S WILLIAM
TEMPLETON HISTORIAN FROM BLACK
BUSINESS MONTH. THANK YOU- MS
WEBER AND WE DO HAVE TO. A
PRIMARY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
GENTLEMEN YOU'RE BOTH JUST TO
CHARLES AND JOHN. IF YOU COULD
CONFINE YOUR TOTAL COMMENTS THE
THREE MINUTES THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. AFTER WE HEAR FROM
OUR PRIMARY- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA THEN GO TO-
OTHER WITNESSES AND AT THAT
POINT YOU WILL JUST SAY YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION. SO WITH THAT I WILL-
TURN IT OVER TO OUR PRIMARY-
SUPPORTERS WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE
I BELIEVE. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR
CHARLES TUNES PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BACK TO DO SO SEE
ATION. AND WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR OF A THE EIGHT FIVE. I
WANT TO THANK DOCTOR WEBER
ANOTHER LEAVE. OF ACA FOR THE
LEADERS ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MAJOR. GFA IS AN ANTI RACISM
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF REPEALING
THE PROVISIONS ENACTED BY
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE IT'S
HAD A DEVASTATING IMPACT THE
MINORITY EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
FUNDED INSTITUTIONS. OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. VIOLATE THE SPIRIT
OF THE CAL MAN PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR MANY STUDENTS TO
OBTAIN AND AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE HIGH QUALITY PUBLIC
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES ARE PROHIBITED BY
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE FROM
ENGAGING IN TARGETED OUT REACH
AND EXTRA EFFORTS TO
MATRICULATING HIGH PERFORMING
MINORITY STUDENTS. OR OVER
HIRING FACULTY OF COLOR HAS
BEEN STALEMATED BY PROPOSITION.
OH NINE. WELL THERE ARE SOME
CALLS SO WITH A- BY SO A ONE
TIME UP AND BEING OF COURSE AND
MAILING. THEY AGENT. THE IMPACT
ON MY NO OWNED BUSINESS SINCE
NINETY. FAR OUT WEIGH WELL WE
NEED TO AND IN THIS MADE.
IMPACT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE IS THAT
IN THE NOT OF SUCKS. COMMITTEE
PLEASE JOIN EFFORTS IN GRAY AND
CAL. AND SUPPORT ACA BY. WOULD
BE THREE I URGE YOUR SO. AND I
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO. TODAY.
GOOD MORNING JOE WILLIAMS IN
SUPPORT OF AC. I INCORPORATED
STATE AND WE COULD BE DID YOU
HI AND REFERS TO EIGHTY EIGHT
DOLLARS YEAH IN BLACK WHITE
AVERAGE IN SENTENCES. OP ED IN
THE CAR NO THE LOSS OF THREE
POINT FIVE BE AND IT'S BLACK
WITH. SIXTY PER DECLINE IN ALL
OWNERS OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS THIS IS THE LEGACY OF
CROP YOU'LL. GOOD IN CONTEXT
YEAH HOW UNTIL I TWO AGE THE
BAY AND. WHAT MADE ON THE
GOLDEN STATE. SO IN THE NAME OF
GLADYS. TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD WORKERS ARGUABLY
ECONOMISTS ARE KING IT WOULD
BAKER OF THE Y. THINKERS WHO
DECIDE TO GET CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BREAKING THAT. WELL PLAYED.
BATTLES ROBERTSRALPH BUNCHE
JACKIE ROBINSON EARL WARREN
HE'LL BE OUT. THREE A DESKTOP
WHY ANNUAL AGED SHOP I IMPLORE
YOU TO YOU. EXTEND THE SAME
PRIVILEGES TEXAS SOUTH FLORIDA
INDIANA WE'RE OUT. THERE AS THE
ILLINOIS IN OHIO IN ORDER. FOR
EIGHTY FIVE TO THE FULL SENATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHEREVER WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS IN THE
CHAMBERS WITH US TODAY IF YOU
COULD CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION SINCE WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR PRIMARY- WITNESSES AND
THEY EXCEEDED THE TIME LIMIT
JUST ONLY SLIGHTLY SO THANK YOU
SIR PLEASE TELL US WHO YOU ARE.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS LOTS AND
EIGHTY AWAY AS SACRAMENTO IT IT
WAS CALIFORNIA- LET THE VOTERS
DECIDE VOTE YES ON A CA FAR. IS
THERE SOMEONE ELSE UP THERE YOU
ARE TELL US WHO YOU ARE. GOOD
MORNING KIM MEN'S WITH ACA-
WITH A DOES SACRAMENTO AID AS
CALIFORNIA. URGING A YES VOTE
ON A CA FIVE. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NO ONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS BUT
I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME FOLKS
IN TWENTY FORTY. SH IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A
CA FIVE. I DON'T THINK ANYONE
HAS GONE TO THE MICROPHONE. NO
ONE WENT TO THE MICROPHONE OKAY
WE WILL GO TO OUR ON LINE AND
AGAIN FOR FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
QUEUE ONLINE THIS IS THE
SUPPORT. POSITION ON A CA FIVE.
AND IF YOU COULD CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION-
WE WOULD APPRECIATE IT SO
MODERATOR PLEASE TAKE OVER IT
AGAIN ACA FIVE NOT A CA SIX.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE CALLING
FOR ANY OTHER BUILDING A FEE A
FIVE YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF BY
PRESSING ONE DIDN'T ZERO. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE DIDN'T ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER
IN PLACE YOU BACKING Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF A FIELD FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE NOW. ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIRMAN. ONE
MOMENT SIR. PEOPLE ARE. LINE.
ONE THREE NINE. ONE MOMENT
DETERMINE.
ONE MORE TIME OVER
THE LINE DETERMINE. WELL I ONE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY KATRINA
RENDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND TWO FOUR EIGHT
A FIVE. YEAR. THANK YOU AND
LINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE ONE FIVE ZERO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ECONOMY CITY WITH
EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE STATE
PARK. THANK YOU AND MY NUMBER
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE THREE
THERE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS LEE HUGE
YEAH A LONG TRACY ON MOLD
BECAUSE THE CORPSMAN I HAVE.
GROUP ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE TO
HOLD STRONG COLD. I SEE A FIVE
THANK YOU AND AGAIN THIS IS THE
SUPPORT FOR A CA FIVE POSITION
THE OPPOSE WILL COME LATER BUT
THANK YOU FOR READING YOUR
COMMENTS THERE NOTED PLEASE
SUPPORTERS OF AC A FIVE. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THEIR
MONTHLY JET ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SHAMPOO OFFICE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
YEAH IN LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING HANNAH BAGHDAD
WITH THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SHANNON STRONG SUPPORT OF THE.
ONE MOMENT. IN LINE. ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
ONE ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS HELLO AGAIN WHAT
BEGINNING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS DR
DOUBLE WANT TO GO AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU IN LINE.
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COUNTRY JOHN
MUHAMMAD EIGHTY OR LOS ANGELES
EIGHTY ELECT CALIFORNIA AND THE
24% AFRICAN AMERICAN FOX THE
USE THAT WARD TO THE STATE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU IN LINE ONE
THIRTY FOUR YEAH LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS BECAUSE SANDRA
JENNINGS AND I'M PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
URBAN LEAGUE ON BEHALF OF ALL
THAT URBAN LEAVING CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
WELL AC EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT THE TERM IN THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. MAYBE A LINE ITEM
YOU LINE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO MY ONE
NINETY ONE NINE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF ECA FIVE. THANK YOU IN LINE
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE SIX NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CAROLON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EASY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN LINE
ONE SIXTY SEVEN ONE SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT COMING OUT HE WITH
H. SO YOU'LL CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN LINE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'M MAUREEN LADY FOUNDER OF OUR
OUR STRATEGY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE NATIONAL. WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS I STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHT
TWO EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND MY NUMBER NINETY NINE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING MY NAME
IS ALICIA YET WE FOUND SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND SHALL
RECORD OF EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU AND MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE TWO NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT. ARE WE GIVING
BUT ONE MOMENT. IN LINE WITH
TWENTY NINE PLEASE RE QUEUE
LINE ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE ONE NINE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOURNALING
STAPLETON PUBLIC POLICY OFFICER
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOUR- HI-
MY NAME IS CONNIE CHAN ON THE
UNDER REPRESENTED OFFICER. FOR
THE UC IT IT SAYS THE CALL AND
FIRST. FOR EIGHTY FIVE IF YOU.
THANK YOU AND LAW SEVEN FOUR
YOUR LONG IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I GOOD MORNING MANY IS
LARRY KING WHAT THE DANCER
PROJECT. AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NINE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
JERRY NIXON I'M A STUDENT AT UC
SAN DIEGO CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU AND I ONE NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE ONE NINE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
DEMANDS THAT HE FROM UC SAN
DIEGO. AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU I NINE TWO ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO
BEAUTIFULLY SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI AND ON OR AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO. EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
NINE HUNDRED AND WITH WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF CHANGE WERE
JUST AS THE NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE PART. IN LINE TWO ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TWO ZERO FIVE. MY
NAME IS NATALIE RECALL LAW I'M
AND I'M A RESIDENT OF SOUTH
AFRICA THE GIRL AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS EIGHT. FIVE
THANK YOU IN LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALLOW ME OF USING YOUR
FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE THANK.
THANK YOU IN LINE ONE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE ONE
EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE MATTER NOT LIKE HOLD PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG WORK IN
YOUR. THANK YOU LINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE ONE TWO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU. YOU CAN
GO AHEAD SO WE CAN HEAR YOU
LINE ONE TWENTY. OKAY LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAYBE A LINE THAN ME.
LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL MOVE ON HOW LONG ONE
FORTY ONE FOR THEIR OLDER LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SHIFTING
GEARS FROM UC IRVINE CALLING
TRUNKS PART OF THE FEEDBACK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE.
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY FIVE YOU MUST REACH YOU
YOU'VE LOCKED OUT LINE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI MY NAME. IF APPROVED
FROM CHINESE REFORM ACTION.
CHINESE WORKING FAMILIES
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE SIX ONE. LINE
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME'S KATHLEEN HAND YOU CAN
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
MA'AM. AND SHE'S DROPPED ONE
ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANYONE IN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF EDUCATION TRANSPLANT
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
COALITION. REPRESENTING THREE
HUNDRED OF THE LEADING LABOR
BUSINESS STUDENTS THE WHOLE
RIGHT ORGANIZATION COMMUNITY
LEADERS. AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU IN LINE EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING MY NAME
IS GWEN CODER AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA GRADUATE
COMPRESSIONAL STUDENT. COUNCIL
WHICH REPRESENTS MORE THAN
SIXTY THOUSAND GRADUATE
STUDENTS ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM
CALLING AND STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHT FIVE. A LINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE FORTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING. AND THEN HI- MY NAME
IS ISABEL MITCHELL AND FOR ME
THE SANTA BARBARA AND I AM
REPRESENTING OUT JUST FOR
TRANSPARENCY THE COMMUNICATIONS
COMMUNICATION DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMISSION FOR
I'LL BET. AND RESIDENTS OKAY
AND I IN SUPPORT OF ACTIVE LIVE.
THANK YOU IN LINE ONE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE SIX TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN ONE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE FIVE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXS
GOSSELIN FROM SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JANA GEARY I'M A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND I LIVE IN ANTHONY
PORTANTINO DISTRICT I'M CALLING
IN STRONG. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWO ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD TWO OH SEVEN. NINE TWO
ZERO SEVEN MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE.
LINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
SEVENTY SIX. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME SURPLUS MONEY GOES WAY I'M
FROM UC BERKELEY IN CALLING IN
STRONG. THANK YOU NINE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
NOT A SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JANE
HEAD AND I'M A UNDERGRADUATE
YOU KEEP BERKELEY CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VERONICA I'M WITH LOS ANGELES
BLACK WORKERS DINNER AND I AM A
STRONG SUPPORTER EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TIFFANY
QUARRELS AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF EIGHTY ONE WHAT THE
ANGELES AND CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY. EIGHT FIVE. NINE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING SUSAN NESSMAN ON BEHALF
OF SPEAK UP UNITED PARENTS LOS
ANGELES ALL K. THROUGH TWELVE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ACA FIVE THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD LORD LINE- PLACE
ON WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION UP AND THEN TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
FORTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
FOUR MAYBE YOU'RE LYING TO ME.
LINE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ALL
RIGHT. IN ON MONDAY ALEX NARAL.
UC'S BARBARA AND I'M A CO CHAIR
OF UCI'S BE LOBBYIST AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EACH YEAR. AND ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS- ULTRA
MACHE ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ASSOCIATION CALLING IN.
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING TURN SENATORS MY
NAME CAN WEIGH IN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE AND
CONSUMER ATTORNEY THE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE EXPECTING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. NUMBER FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR THEIR
ROLE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CRYSTAL GORDON CALLING WITH
EIGHTY OS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE ACA FLAT. THANK YOU.
IN MY NUMBER SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL COLEMAN ORGANIZER THE
ASSN LOCAL THIRTY NINETY NINE
AND BARBARA LIME AND RESONANT
CORALS CALIFORNIA. ON THE
STRONG SUPPORTER THEY SEE IF
I'VE. LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY
NAME IS A MARA WILSON CALLING
WITH EIGHTY O. S. LOS ANGELES
EIGHTY OS CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS A MARATHON THANK
HEAVEN THE ELECTED EXTERNAL
VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE UCLA
STUDENT BODY AND I'M PROUD TO
SAY UCLA STUDENTS AREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS CATHERINE PHILLIPS
WOULD HEAR CLIP CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS MARIA
MARTINEZ I CURRENTLY SERVE AT
THE UNDERGRADUATE CONCERN
AUTHORED BY PRESIDENT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
I REPRESENT OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND I'M
CALLING INTO. CALLING IT TODAY
TO AVOID OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FIVE AND WE HOPE THAT
THE COMMUNITY YEAH THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FORTY. GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
THAT F. RELIEF THAT THEIR LAND
I'M CALLING FROM A DEAL AT LOS
ANGELES AND A DEAL AT
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO PROUD TO
LEARN THAT UC SAN DIEGO AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CLICK HERE BOB DOLE BUT
LOCKED INTO THE COUNTY WITH BE
OUT. LA AND COMMUNITY COALITION
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF A
THREE EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY DIRE I'M WITH
A DEAL AT CALIFORNIA EIGHT HBOS
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A THREE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE FORTY ONE MAYBE
YOU'RE IN YOU. LINE ONE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I'M JENNIFER LOOSE
AFTER THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
A FIVE. NINE ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
AND THE TEENAGERS MY NAME
PLEDGING FUN CUTTING FROM THE
CITY OF IRVINE. AND AT THE
CHINESE AMERICAN I'M CALLING
SHOULDER THE PORT FOR THE
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOR MORE THAT ADELINE I AM AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY AND I'M CALLING FOR
WILL SUPPORT. OF THE FIVE THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE TWENTY EIGHT ONE
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M CARLA
JENKINS FROM A DEALER LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT AN ACA FIVE. NINE ONE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS I WOULD
REALLY RATES CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT EACH YEAR. MIND
IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL HI
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE YEAH
L. G. B. JOB IN THE NATION I
WOULD TO A SOLID AND MEMBERS
ONLY CLOSE AZ AT THIS TOTALLY
INTO MEASURE. LINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE ONE TWO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES I WHIMS
AB OS BAY AREA AND US
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
A CA FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TO THEIR OLD TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO
ZERO TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS.
HELEN ME AND I'M IN ACADEMICS
DIDN'T EMPLOYEE AT UCSD AND A
MEMBER OF OUR UNION UAW TWO
EIGHT FIVE I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB FIVE. LINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING. YES WE
CAN IS THERE. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS VINCENT ROCK SO I'M
CURRENTLY THE UNDERGRADUATE
EXTERNAL VICE PRESIDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND I'M CALLING AND STRONG
SUPPORTER IF YOU I URGE YOUR I.
THANK YOU. NINE TWO ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AT TYLER I
DO ARMY HALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT EACH YEAR
FIVE THANK YOU. NINE TO TWELVE
YOUR MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M NOT A WHAT ARE THE
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA EDGE
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CALM HIM SHE
ON BEHALF OF YOUR W. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE REPRESENTING
OVER NINETEEN THOUSAND ACADEMIC
STUDENT EMPLOYEES OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THESE. ARE. NINE
TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. YES HI THIS ISSUE
INCLUDING CALLING FROM
SUNNYVALE. FIVE LEGALIZED. LINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEARING ARE WE
CAN HEAR YOU NOW. YEAH MY NAME
IS MARLENE HEARD STUDENT AT
COLLEGE I'M ALSO THE
COMMUNICATIONS OF. THE BLACK
MARKET OKAY WE GET YOU TO
COLLUDED. SUPPORT OF HE. FIVE
THANK YOU IN LINE TO TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ERICA
ROMERO ON THE HELP OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A FEW FIVE
THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY NINE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY NINE MAY BE
ALIGNED ON MUTE. ON THE OTHER
IS THE DOCK WE CALL CALL YOU
PHAM US THE JOSE I'M ONLY THANK
YOU DAVE ARE YOU AWARE COUPLE
TELL THE AND BUT- AS- AGAINST
THE. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE ACT.
ONE TO TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS JAMIE FROM WANTED TO CREATE
A CALIFORNIA I ONLY OPPOSED TO
TWENTY FIVE AND- THE GENTLEMAN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OF A CA. BOB LINE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY FIVE MAYBE
YOUR ON MUTE. ONE TWO TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
TWO TO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LEASES TAX CUTS OFF FROM CHINO
HILLS. YEAH MOST MOMS I KNOW
YOU KNOW THEY ARE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY FIVE. ONCE AGAIN
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
IN SUPPORT OF WINE TO TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
HELLO GOOD MORNING HELLO MY
NAME IS CALLING FROM TURNING
INTO CALIFORNIA MY NAME IS AMY
WE WORK AT A SET AS AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER ON THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY- I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE CA FIVE NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF
AND MY KIDS ALL THE KIDS I GREW
UP IN THE PROJECTS WITH IT
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO MAKE IT
OUT. SEN THANK YOU MEMBERS.
NINE TO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS GABRIELLE AS THE OLD
ONE I'M CALLING AS A STUDENT
FROM UC SANTA BARBARA I'M
ORIGINALLY FROM SOUTH IT IN A
AND IT LAUP ME WHAT DO YOU WANT
THE IN DOWN HERE THE DISTRICT
THAT WERE HAVE REAL IN THE
UNDER FUNDED AND TALKS SO MANY
BARRIERS TO AYE HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR MANY STUDENTS
HERE. FOR MAJORITY LOW INCOME
AND MINORITYTHIS BILL WOULD
CREATE EQUITY- TO YOUR POSITION
SO FOR ALL SUBSEQUENT SPEAKERS
IF YOU COULD CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LYING TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS BRIAN
HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WERE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE ZERO FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI MY NAME IS THE MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE INCOMING
REGIONAL. THE REGION TO STEP
OUT. CALIFORNIA CLEAN COLLARS
STREET BILLION I'M A CO THE
ACTING PRESIDENT CRITICAL
FAMILY COLLEGE CALLING IN ORDER
TO EAT THE ON. NINE TWO ZERO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWO THERE ARE
NOT YOU'RE LYING TO ME. HI GOOD
MORNING- HERE IN SENATOR MY
NAME IS HOW YOU SHOULD BROWN ON
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AFRICAN
AMERICAN POCKETS. I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND THE
CAUCUS MEMBERS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ACA FIVE IN HOPE YOU
ALL POLL YEAH. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING WRITING HISTORY PRIOR
FROM EIGHTY OLD RADIO AT LOS
ANGELES AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE FIRST PRACTICAL NINE AT U.
P. BERKELEY IN CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE TO
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO ONE NINE.
HI DIDN'T QUITE TIME- I- IN
VENTURA COUNTY I WANTED A BIG
NOW TO EIGHTY EIGHT CAR. THANK.
NINE TO THIRTY FIVE THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OF A CA FIVE ONE TWO
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM WHEN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A THREE EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYWAY WHAT
THAT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF A FINAL LIKE
TO THANK DOCTOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD THANK YOU. THE LINE.
TWO FORTY TWO FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CURTIS LING THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO THIRTY TWO
THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
THIRTY MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE.
LINE TWO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE TWO THREE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THAT THE KING WHEN DEAN
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR ACT POLICY LINK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A THREE EIGHT
FIVE. NINE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE FOUR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FORTY
SIX MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE. LINE
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE TWENTY MAY BE ON MUTE.
NINE TO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
ONE SEVEN. GOOD MORNING THAT
THE THEIR PARK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CALLING TO DAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL I WANTED TO TAKE
MAYBE YOUR LINES AND YOU.
MEMBERS THIS IS CALIFORNIA
POLITICS LUCIEN RELAPSE REGARD
WITH THE OCULUS INTO THE CENTER
FOR AFRICAN PEACE AND CONFLICT
RESOLUTION RIGHT AFTER THE
LOCAL CREATE AN IMPRESSION
PROBLEMS IN THE CITY OF
PROBABLY ALWAYS SUPPORT.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO FOUR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ALEX YOU ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
COALITION FOR ECONOMIC EQUITY
AND THE ASSOCIATION OF ASIAN
AMERICAN ATTORNEY IN CPA FIRMS
AND I'M CALLING. SELECT A PORT
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PRIZE WITH MICHAEL MEN'S
STUDENT FROM EACH BERKELEY AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF BURKE AT YOUR
COOPERATIVE WHAT'S OUT THERE'S
RIGHT NOW LOW INCOME STUDENTS
INCREDIBLY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE FIVE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE
SIXTY TWO MAYBE LINE THEN YOU.
NINE TO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING HI MY NAME IS KALINA
SIEGEL AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIVE. YOUR. LINE. TWO FIFTY ONE
TWO FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AND HAPPY LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF DOZENS OF
GRASSROOTS RACIAL EDUCATION
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE TWO FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
AN ON THE S. TRAVIS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CHAVEZ THE TO THE
TRAVIS FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO KNOW THE SUPPORT
OF THE UNITED FARM WORKERS IN
THE LORD'S WORK BUT FOUNDATION
THANK YOU. LINE TWO FIFTY FOUR
TO FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LINDA ESCALANTE ARE YOU STILL A
LOT NINE SEVEN CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. FOR THE
NATIONAL SOURCE THE- HELPFUL OR
ENERGY SEE PROBABLY HERE ON
CAPITOL THAT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
ACTIVISTS IN CALIFORNIA TO
REGISTER A STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. LINE ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU. LEARNING
MY NAME IS LAWRENCE SANDERS-
ACTUALLY CALLING ON BEHALF OF.
THE BLACK COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON
ACTUALLY THE PRESIDENT. AND I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING CHAFEE
COLLEGE STUDENT GOVERNMENT THE-
AUTOMATIC CUCAMONGA AND WE'RE
CALLING IT THE CLINTON EIGHTEEN.
FLYING TO TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY TO TWENTY THREE MAYBE ON
MUTE. LINE TWO SIX SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO SIX SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HI MY NAME IS EMILY CHANG
FROM SAN GABRIEL I AM CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. LINE TWO
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE TWO SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS THE
ROAD QUIRK CONTE FROM THE-
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE IDEA CON-
SENIOR AT UC BERKELEY AND
RESIDENT OF AS YOU TWENTY
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE P. FIVE. LINE TWO SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
TWO SIX EIGHT. GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS COREY HERNANDEZ I'VE
BEEN OUR COMMON BOND- CHIRLA I
AM POLICY INTERN SO LET THE
COALITION OF HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ITEMS IN STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. NINE
TO THIRTY TWO THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYBE A LINE THEN YOU TO THIRTY
NINE TWO THREE THEIR OLDER LINE
IS OPEN. LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWO SEVEN ONE. GOOD
MORNING MARTHA'S THEIR AGO SAID
HE HAS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA
FIVE PLEASE VOTE YES ON THE
BILL THANK YOU. ONE TO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SIX
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN MAY BE ALIGNED ON
MUTE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS EMILY CHEN CALLING FROM
TANK A DEAL I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AC A FIVE.
LINE TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING JOHN I'M SORRY
OF COURSE EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
SO FOR EVERYBODY ONLINE WE ARE
IN THE SUPPORT. PORTION OF THE
TESTIMONY SO PLEASE SUPPORTERS
OF ACA FIVE STAY IN THE QUEUE
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO A CA
FIVE WITHDRAW FROM THE QUEUE
AND THEN COME BACK IN WHEN WE
GET TO THE OPPOSITION. WE'RE
TRYING TO HEAR FROM THE
SUPPORTERS NOW AND THEN THE
OPPOSITION WILL HAVE THEIR
OPPORTUNITY AFTERWARDS SO
SUPPORTERS OF ACA FIVE PLEASE
CONFINE YOURSELF TO YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT SO
THERE ARE NO MORE. NO MORE
SUPPORTERS OF ACA FIVE IN THE
QUEUE WE DO HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION A WHEN
ONE WOO- FROM THE CALIFORNIANS
FOR EQUAL RIGHTS AND SHE IS ON
THE CO HOST LINE. AND I BELIEVE
SHE'S THE ONLY PRIMARY SPEAKER-
IN OPPOSITION OF ACA FIVE AND
SO IF YOU COULD CONFINE
YOURSELF. TO THE THREE MINUTE
TIME LIMIT THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED AND PLEASE- I
BELIEVE YOU'RE READY SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BE A MEMBER OF
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GOING ON I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR EQUAL RIGHTS A
DIVERT SPOT BASED COALITION
NATION PROPOSITION ONE NINE.
ONE YEAR WEEK ALL RIGHT HAD THE
SUPPORT THEY- HUNDRED THIRTY
SELDOM EASY TO. HE HELLO. I'LL
COALITION IS LED BY FORMER UC
RAGIN WHAT KIND OF THE
COALITION STRONGLY OPPOSES ACA
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE PACKARD
ALREADY MA'AM CALIFORNIA BUDGET
THANK YOU CAN YOU CREEK
EXPONENTIALLY ALL THE PEOPLE
HAVE A CONTRACT. DISPARITIES
STUDY PROVIDE DIVERSE EQUITY
OFFICE. OFFICERS AND WE-
COMMENTS. CONTRACTING ACCORDING
TO A PURELY THAT AND UC SANTA
CRUZ ECONOMY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF. SAVE SIX WHAT
SIX ONE DOLLARS BETWEEN NINE
NINETY. NINETY NINE EXTRA COST.
WITH PREFERENCES ABOUT ONE
TWENTY DOLLAR AFTER PROPOSITION
TWO ONE NINE THE PRICES ON
STATE FUNDED CONTRACT FELL BY
FIVE POINT 6% RELATIVE TO
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROJECT.
POLICE HAVE YOU APPLIED. OVER
TIME THERE WOULD. WITH MOST
LIKELY COST STATE BILLION OF
DOLLARS CALL IMPACT OF FIVE
MONTHS BE EVALUATED IN HO CHI.
OF ALL OF ISSUE EIGHTY FIVE IN
REALITY THINK NINETEEN NINETY
SIX CALIFORNIA HAS MAKES RIGHT
IN DIVERT PRETTY AND CRUCIAL
PUBLIC EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT AND
CONTRACTING. UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES HAVE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT GAINS LONG AND
GRADUATION AT BOTH UC AND CSU
BOTH WOMEN AND MEN OF COLOR THE
LARGEST GAIN IN CLEVELAND RATE
PROPORTIONAL TO THE WORKING.
AGE POPULATION WELL. THE
GOVERNMENT MATCH MASON SAID. ON
AC FIVE ON NECESSARY WILL
GREATLY HARMED. PACKS ECONOMY
PRODUCTION AND HAD. THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULDN'T BE. THANK
REDISTRIBUTION OF OPTIONS. IF I
THE VALUE THE MERIT PRINCIPLE
WHICH HAVE IMITATED HOW DID
SUCCESS. GROUPS AGAINST THE
OTHER WELL ON THE WAY. OF OUR
SOCIETY ALL WE TAXPAYER MONEY.
I HOPE JOINING DOESN'T
CATEGORICALLY AND AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION. ALEX I THANK A FAMILY
MATCHES. ON THE OTHER HAND A
FEW FIVE IS ABOUT RESTORING GOT.
BASED THE FACT THEY HAVE A LEAD
DISCRIMINATION ALREADY MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA THAT AGAIN INCREASE
EXPLAINED. PHONE NUMBER ONE
EIGHT THREE FIVE YOU KNOW THANK
YOU FOR YOUR. THANK YOU THERE
ANYONE THE- CHAMBER WHO WISH
THIS. IN OF ACA FIVE WE HEARD
FROM MY PRIMARY SPEAKER SO IF
YOU CAN CONFINEMENT OF TO YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION AND IF YOU COULD KEEP
YOUR MASK ON WE WANT TO MAKE
IT'S- RESPECT SOCIAL DISTANCING
SO EVEN WHEN YOU TESTIFY
ANYBODY OUT THERE. WE STILL
WANT YOU TO WEAR YOUR MASK SO
THANK YOU SIR PLEASE TELL US
YOUR NAME. AND YOUR POSITION.
THIS IS THE XIN XIN DON'T FROM
THE SAN JOSE OF FROM WISEMAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THEY SAY FIVE
THANK YOU. NEXT SPEAKER. I AM
SAYING HE IS DOING AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE A CA FIVE THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS SELENA CHIU EVER
EVER VISIT THE UNDER FIFTY
DOLLARS IN A SIGNATURE IS
COLLECTED ON CHANGE DOT ORG TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE A CA FIVE.
THANK YOU. NEXT BAKER THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD HELLO I'M YOUNG FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY OPPOSE A
CA FIVE. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE CHAMBERS SEEING NO ONE
ELSE WE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. PLEASE RESPECT SOCIAL
DISTANCING KEEP YOUR MASS ON
AND SAY YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MY NAME IS BABY DE AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE STATE TO
COMBINE A WOMAN'S ALLIANCE I'M
ALSO THE BOARD MEMBER OF
NOTHING CALIFORNIA ENGINEER
GROUP REPRESENTING MORE THAN
TOOLS ALL THEN THE MEMBERS WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED BEING A
STATE FIVE. THE MISSION SHOULD
NOT BE MADE WE'RE ON WE'RE ON
NAME ORGAN. AND POSITION THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER. HOW GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE I'M TRONG TEN
AND SAY A HERE I PRESENT IT-
NINE FIVE ONE TWO FOUR KNOW
HE'LL TACK LABOR COULD PEOPLE
WE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE BE BECAUSE HE'S A
FIVE WILL BE BACK THANK YOU
WERE JUST. WE'RE NOT WITH X.
GAME INCREASE EXCUSE. CHECK ME
FOR ALL FOLKS WHO CUTE UP WE
OUR COMMENTARY ON OPPOSITION-
WE ARE NOW IN THE FACE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ADDING THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATION AND JUST
THEIR POSITION WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANY MORE SPEECHES- EITHER
BEFORE BY THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE BOTH SIDES HAVE HAD
THEIR ALLOTTED TIME LIMIT SO
NOW THESE ARE ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS. NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS AND THEN. FROM CENTER
SEPARATE CORRECT SORRY FOR A-
SACRAMENTO. I'M A POLICY TO YOU
ARE POSTED HERE. ARE YOU SEE.
THERE'S THREE VERY. THREE AS I
SAY I FIVE THANK YOU. THE BURLY
MY NAME IS STILL YEAH AND FROM
FREMONT I STRONGLY OPPOSE OF
ASIC A FIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
TWENTY FORTY- WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AGAIN THIS IS
OPPOSITION TO A SEE A FIVE
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR PRIMARY
SPEAKERS PLEASE CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
MODERATOR THANK YOU. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE CALLING ON
A NOTHER BILL OR IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TWO ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
SO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AC A
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL. AN OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACKING Q. ONCE AGAIN
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIVE
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWO FIVE ZERO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DON OPTION AND
I'M CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY- AND I AM CO FOUNDER OF
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR EQUITY.
RIGHT NOT OP ED SHEERAN
THINKING ACCOUNTING SERVING
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN THE PREMIER
THE BASIC OF GENDER- GREAT-
AGAIN I'M CALLING AND I'VE BEEN
TRYING. TO CALL FOR THE PAST
TWO HOURS. FOR EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE TWO ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MEMBERS SIGNED A
SENATOR I'M MY NAME IS BEING
FOUND I'M FROM SOUTH CALIFORNIA
ASIAN AMERICAN FEDERATION.
PLEASE DROP ME OFF HOW EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANKS YEAR.
NINE ONE ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
ZERO SEVEN MAY BE ALIGNED ON
MUTE. THEN WE'LL MOVE N TO
LINE TWO SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAYBE A LINE THEN YOU
NINE TO SEVENTY NINE. YES IT.
TWO SEVENTY NINE YOU NEED TO Q.
BACK UP LINE ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE NINETEEN MAYBE ONLINE
THEN YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CANDACE CLEAR FRONT
FRESNO COUNTY AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CHINESE CULTURE AT THE STATION
WE REPRESENT MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND ASIAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'LL AND ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF MONTH WHILE
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MOMS. WITH KIDS IN K.
TO TWELVE WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE AND- ALSO
LIKE TO THANK YOU. NEXT SPEAKER
RENDON FIFTY FIVE LINE TO FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO BE A
REAL HEAD AND REMEMBER WE'RE IN
THE OCEAN OF THE TESTIMONY.
WERE IN THE MOTION OF THE
TESTIMONY WERE ONLY HEARING
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
WELL GO AHEAD NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY. YES
MY NAME IS RARELY WRONG THE
FACTORS. I AM GOING TO THERE
AND- UCLA ASIAN STUDENT. I'M
HERE TO STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
MAYBE YOUR LINES ON MUTE. NINE
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE DAY YES WE CAN GO HERE YOU
GO AHEAD. THIS IS LINDA PLATE-
FROM AMERICAN RENT. ON A HE IN
LA GRANGE NINE ONLY A PUBLIC.
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE. NINE TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY TWO
SEVEN MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE. TWO
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO FIVE EIGHT.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU MA'AM. MY
GAME CALIFORNIA RIGHT THE ONLY
ALL. RIGHT THANK YOU. NINE TWO
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MIND TO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS LYNN GATHERED
FROM FOSTER CITY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A STATE PARK THANK YOU.
MINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD I'LL- I'LL-
YES. MY NAME IS THE M. MEDIA
I'M CALLING FROM KATIE ALONG
WITH ALL TRYING TO INCREASE.
HOUSE WE JOHNNY UPLOAD EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING YEAH HE CALLING
FROM SAN JOSE A MECHANIC OUR
UNIVERSITY GRADUATE AND I'M
STRONG OPPOSING A FIGHT BECAUSE
ITS NECK TO THE IMPACT THE CARD.
LINE. TWO SIXTY EVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
EMILY CHANG CALLING FROM SAN
GABRIEL I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. I'M BETTING
THAT FROM ME I STAND UP AND DO
IT THIRTY EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
AND I STRONGLY HOLD EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE FOUR OUR CHILDREN. AHEAD
GRACE HI MY NAME'S GRACE CHAIN
FROM SUNNYVALE AND I'M
REPRESENTING CHALLENGER BAY
AREA PARENT GROUP OVER FIVE
HUNDRED E. PARENT WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE ANY SEE FIVE BECAUSE YOU
WILL DECREASE CALIFORNIA'S.
LINE TWO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO EIGHT ONE. HELLO THIS IS A
LIFE LONG I READ THROUGH THE
END. ATTY A I AND BIG THEY
ASSOCIATION WHICH HAS THINK
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD WHEN JOHNNY
HELLO. EIGHT FIVE I'M FROM NOT.
LINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO
EIGHT FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KIM CHAN FROM SAN JOSE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M CALLING FROM LOS
GATOS. COUNTY ON THE WEEKEND I
TEACH A GROUP OF CHINESE AND
INDIAN STUDENTS THAT DIDN'T ALL
AROUND OF MERIT BASED-
OPPORTUNITY EDUCATION
REPUBLICANS RIGHT SO I WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE APA FIVE THANK
YOU. NINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE SEVENTY MAY BE ALIGNED
THEM YOU. ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE TWO FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING INSURANCE NUMBERS ON
THIS MOVIE THANK CALLING FROM
PALO ALTO CALIFORNIA AND THE UC
BERKELEY PHD GRADUATE IN
ENGINEERING AND I WILL CHINESE
AMERICAN WOMEN- I STRONGLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWO SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IN A
TEAM OF FROM WHAT THE WHOLE
THING I REPRESENT FIVE THOUSAND
ALREADY DONE IN OUR AREA WITH
TRONG MY HOPE IS A FIVE. LINE
TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
EIGHTY THREE. HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU THERE. BUT INTO THE GARDEN
COMING FROM WITHIN THE VEIL
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH HUNDREDS
OF HELLO BUT CURRENT FROM DREAM
ALL UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE WANT TO SELL TO A. FIVE NINE
ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU MA'AM.
OKAY YEAH HELLO MY NAME ONLY I
PHAM FREMONT. EIGHT BOB A HAND
UP YEAH ON. I'LL GO FROM APPLE
EIGHT EIGHT. YEAH NINE ONE SIX
EIGHT YOUR LONG IS OPEN ONE SIX
EIGHT I DON'T ALLOW YOU. SO CAN
I DO FOR YEAH THE THIS IS ALL I
WANT SIXTY YOUR HONOR OPEN. I'M
SORRY. THE KNOW WHAT OKAY LET
LINE BUT MAY NOT FOUR OKAY I
WAS LOOKING ONLINE. WHAT IT ONE
MOMENT. AND YOUR MIND AGAIN
NINETEEN YOUR LONG IS OPEN
PLEASE GOING LINE NINETY. HI
HIGHLIGHTED A MEMBER THERE YOU.
I DO WAY PUNK FROM VENTURA
COUNTRY I REFUSE THEM- WHEN
YOU'RE COUNTY CHINESE PARENTS
GROUP- I WANT TO SAY BIG NOW TO
A CA FIVE. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
FIVE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
ALIGNED ON MUTE. LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX SHE. LINE FORTY TWO FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD I'M SORRY LINE TO NINETY
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWO NINE ZERO. HI IT'S ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU MA'AM. THE
MORNING THIS IS SONYA CHOKE ON
THAT THE DEAL ONE NOW I WOULD
BE ANY MORE THAN FORTY LOS AND
THE NINETY ANY NUMBER YOU CAN
GOING OUT WE ARE STRONGLY.
AGAINST EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN LINE FOR TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FORTY TWO MAYBE
ALIGN THEM YOU. LINE. TWO FIFTY
THREE TWO FIVE THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ON YOUR
FINANCIAL FREMONT I STRONGLY
AGAINST IS A FILE BECAUSE IN
COLORADO A LOT. LINE TWO NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE TWO
NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS REVENUE
SO YOU CAN FROM CREE AND THOSE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
DISCRIMINATORY YOU SEE A FIVE.
THANK. NINETEEN NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JENNY
CALLING FROM WHAT THE CITY WITH
THE THINKING OF FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBER OF A LOCAL AGENT HER
COMING HERE GROUP WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE EASIER RIGHT
IT'S A BILL LEGALIZING. THANK
YOU NINE ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAYBE YOU'RE LYING TO
ME ONE OF SEVEN. MY ONE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO MY NAME'S ARTHUR LEE- ON
THE HOUSE SO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
COMPANIES ACTION WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
ONE EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYBE THE LINE THAN ME. LINE
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. LINE TWO
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI SO HE
HE HELLO I REPRESENT FIVE SOME
OF THE PARENTS AND THE CHILDREN
IN FREMONT GOLDEN STATE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU IN LINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
THREE ZERO ZERO GO AHEAD. MAYBE
ALIGNED ON MUTE. LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND- OPEN UP. NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWO SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS STEVE MLLER WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND THE UC
DAVIS GRADUATE CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE RACES
BILL ACA. LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHTY ONE. MAYBE OUR
LINES AND MEET. NINE EIGHTY
ONE. IF I COULD ALSO MAKE
COMMENT TO THE CALLERS THUS
FAR- UP UNTIL THAT POINT.
EVERYBODY'S REFRAIN FROM USING
INFLAMMATORY COMMENTS OR
CHARACTERIZATIONS I WOULD ASK
THE FOLLOWING- SPEAKERS TO KEEP
THAT. KEEP THAT IN MIND AS THEY
MAKE THEIR COMMENTS THIS IS-
CIVIL DISCOURSE ON AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND WITH THAT WILL
CONTINUE WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ONE
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE TWO
ZERO MAYBE LINES ON MUTE. ONE
ONE TWO ZERO. LINE ONE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE ONE ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOT SHOT. LINE
THREE OH FOR. NINE THREE OH FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CRYSTAL
LIEU I AND THE PRESIDENT OF
SILICON VALLEY CHINESE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS I AM- BUT
THE- ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS.
WE ARE EXPECTING OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE THREE ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO REAL
THINK STRAIGHT LINE IS OPEN.
THERE ARE. THIS CALL. RIGHT NOW
THE. THANK YOU. NINE THREE ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
PRONE IRVINE UNIFIED DISTRICT
WHERE. I RIPPED AND THE
THOUSANDS FOR OF ERROR AND- IN
IRVINE EVEN THAT THE- OUR
RIGHTS GOING DISTRICT AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE A THREE FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE TWO FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWO FOUR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
FORTY EIGHT THEIR LINE THEN YOU.
LINE TWO FORTY EIGHT. LINE
THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK THE HIRING SHE FROM THE
ONE NOT AND MY RESTRUCTURING IN
YOUTH THANK GOODNESS.
TRANSPORTATION TO EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING MY NAME TING LITTLE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AC A FIGHT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT WARRANTED TO TRY TO
HELP FROM SAN JOSE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
NINE THREE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
GEORGE LEAVE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
I'M WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY THE
ORANGE CLOCK FOUNDATION. AN
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATING FOR
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF ASIAN AMERICAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA. WEST STRONG
OPPOSED ACA FIGHT BECAUSE IT IS.
WE. NINE THREE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JESSICA FROM FROM CHINO HILLS I
STRONGLY A COLD EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS RYAN ARE I AM FROM SAN
JOSE I'M THE FOUNDER A LONG
CARE GOAL. THE AC HAND IN HAND
WE HAVE OUR OWN ONE HUNDRED
NUMBERS ONE CARES. ABOUT LEON I
IT REPRESENTING DOWN TO THE
STATE OUR STRONG OPPOSITION TO
A THREE EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
THE DEL POLITO COURTING FROM
YOU- BAY AREA HE THE U. S. B.
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE FOUR
THOUSAND TO IT AND FROM THE
PARENT I WOULD SEND THEM TO.
OUR ARE STRONGLY OF IT EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. NINE TO
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME CLEAN COAL FROM WARNER
SCHOOL DISTRICT REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS TO THE
STUDENTSIN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
WORST DROUGHT HOLDS EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. WHAT. ONE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN MAY BE ALIGNED THEM YOU.
HELLO DID IN HELLO. WE CAN HEAR
YOU MA'AM HELLO DATED TODAY NOT
IN FROM SAN DIEGO I REPRESENTED
SAN DIEGO ASIAN AMERICAN FOR
EQUALITY WE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
A CD FIVE. THANK. ONE THREE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MA'AM WE
CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD MORNING MY
NUMBER ALLEN AYE- FROM HER JOHN
HI JOHN UPLAND UNITED SCHOOL. I
RECKON. ASIAN AMERICAN WHILE
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
JOHNNY HOW STRONG APPROACH. FOR
ABOUT EIGHT EIGHT. LINE THREE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH I'M HERE YOU YEAH
THIS IS RACHEL MIGHT WELL I
RIPS INTO A GROUP OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS DâN- CHINO
VALLEY IN YOUR INDUSTRY AYE
OPPOSED EIGHTY FIVEARE WE- ONE
THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY I AM ARE YOU SURE YOU AND
FROM THE SAN DIEGO AND I AM AND
A SOFTWARE ENGINEER I DO ANDY
OPPOSE AZ EIGHTY FIVE. EIGHTY
LINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE DOCTOR FOUND
YOU'RE NOT ALONE LINE FIFTY ON
IT OKAY UP. WHEN I YEAH EACH OF
THE WINTER. LINE THREE EIGHT
YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GONE
HE I'M CALLING FROM CITIZENS.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
JUNIORS IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD HOW
STRONGLY OPPOSING IS HERE.
HELLO. NINE THREE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- I'M A WORKING
MOTHER AND- AND JOHNNY OF
CLOTHING EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE I'M
FROM NORTH DANTE THANK YOU.
NINE THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU MA'AM.
RIGHT MY MAIN LACKEY WELL I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF WHILE THE
COOK FROM THE PARENTS AND A
CLARA STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHT
THREE FIVE. MINE THREE FORTY
FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN THREE
FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARY JOHN FROM
ANY ANGLE I RECORD THEM LIKE
IT'S GONNA OPPOSE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE MY KIDS AMERICAN. LINE
THREE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOW LIMON.
DOUBLING COLLEAGUES- PROFESSOR
PRESENT FIVE HUNDRED TEACHERS
AND ALSO- NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT CAN DOUBLE
CRISIS WE PRESENT- THREE
HUNDRED VOLUNTEER MEMBERS- WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED- ACA FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE THREE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE THREE
FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS THE VIEW FROM THE
OTHER I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. NINE
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE
FORTY ONE. HELLO MAYBE ALIGN
THEM YES MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU.
AND YOUR HAND CUTTING PROMPT AN
ADULT- WE HAD A LOT OF THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS POLITECNICO
ASIAN AMERICAN QUALITY COMEDY
LAYS DOWN APPROACH EIGHT IS
FINE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
AT ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
MA'AM MY NAME IS TO THEM THAT
MUCH FROM PPG IN PASADENA I AM
REPRESENTING FIVE HUNDRED
PARENTS. AND FAMILY AGAIN
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE WE SHOULD NOT.
NINE THREE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MIND THREE ONE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE LINE
THEN YOU. LINE THREE SEVENTEEN.
NINE THREE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS CALLING FILE SHARING
THEM PASSAGE FROM SAN RAMON
CASTRO VALLEY DISTRICT I
REQUEST THEN TO ONE THOUSAND
ASIAN AMERICAN. HERITAGE GROUP
WE HAVE A ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
KATE. ALL REPATRIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSED AC BY WELL. NINE ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ARE SELDOM
GONE ROUND LOS ANGELES COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
THREE SIXTY MAY BE ALIGNED ON
MUTE. HI. WHY DO YOU THINK
THERE'LL BE TO BACK UP ONE
THREE FIFTY SIX THREE FIVE SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY I AM THE
JAIL IS UNIVALLATE LGBT
ELEVATION OUR THREE THOUSAND
MEMBERS STRONGLY OPPOSED. BY A
BIT DISCRIMINATION. LINE TWO
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO
FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME MISSION
NAY ROURKE I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE BUSINESS ADVISORY COUNCIL
AT METRO I AM THE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNER ORGANIZATION THE MOTHER
OF ASIAN STUDENTS. HAVE BEEN ON
HOLD FOR FORTY TWO MINUTES AND
I AM AN ABSOLUTE STRONG SUPPORT
OF EQUITY EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE THREE SIX TWO. HI
YEAH THIS IS A LONG FROM THE
SAN DIEGO. I STRONG I WOULD
PRESENTS THE PARENTS IN POLY
UNIFIED SCHOOL UNIFIED DISTRICT
STRONG OPPOSED AC A FIVE. LINE
THREE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD LINE THREE SIXTY
SIX ALLOW. HELLO AND WE CAN
HEAR YOU LINE DO YOU THINK WE
THINK YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AWAY
FROM WHERE DONALD BEACH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE. IF WE GET. LINE THREE
FIFTY FIVE MODERN A LITTLE
LATER HOLDING TO GO AHEAD A
MODERATOR HOLD ON AGAIN AGAIN
FOLKS IF YOU COULD CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO- YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
AT THIS POINT WE'RE NOT
ENTERTAINING ANYMORE- SPEECHES
OR TESTIMONY ON THE BILL JUST.
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT ACTUALLY ME
AND OPPOSITION THE SUPPORT HAS
ALREADY FOR CLOSE WE ARE NOW ON
THE OPPOSITION SO PLEASE
CONFINE YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. IN LINE THREE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL YES. I AM. ONE
YEAH BUT I'M NOT PRIVATE. AT I
COULD TALK AND I THINK HE SO I
GET THE RECORDS AND I'LL ONE
THOUSAND THE PARENTS AND THE
CHILDREN THE ARE OPEN I'D BE
HERE AND THE WAY STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE EIGHTH GRADE. FIVE
NINE THREE SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE
IS- OPEN THREE SEVEN TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL MY MEDITATION AND-
HI IF WE CAN HEAR YOU. MY NAME
IS NICE YOU I WOULD BE SENT
BACK IN THERE BECAUSE OF GOOD
IDEATION AND THE LITTLE CHINESE
WHAT YOUR COLLATION WHICH WE
HAVE MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY FIVE. LINE THREE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYBE ALIGN THEM. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. FROM WITHIN THEIR
GOAL I'M IN STRONG HOLD ITS
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU LINE
THREE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THREE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAYBE YOUR LINE THEN YOU
WIND. THREE SEVENTY FOUR. LINE
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME IS DONNA BEEN
LONG I'VE REPRESENTED ALUMNI
GROUP THAT YOU SAN DIEGO I'M
ALSO A GRAD STUDENT YOU YOU
CAN'T YOU HE BERKELEY BY
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. LINE TWO EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU FINE
ALL YEAH HI MY NAME IS WHEN SHE
FROM PALO ALTO I'M STRONGLY
AGAINST THE A FIVE THANK YOU.
NINE THREE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BEING NAY FROM SUNNYVALE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE AWAY BATTLE WAY. NINE
THREE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SAN DIEGO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION I WORK. WHY WAS THE
OTHER JAPANESE MEMBERS THE
DALAI OPPOSE IS THERE FIVE.
NINE THREE NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE NINE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M DRAW FROM
SAN JOSE I REPRESENT- THE
OUTCOME BRING NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
WE HAVE WELL FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE- YOUNG WORLD WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHT ZERO FIVE. NINE
THREE NINETY THREE NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAYBE A LINE THAT MEET
THREE NINETY THREE NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AND
THEY DID ME OKAY- MY NAME IS
JAIL WATER PROBLEMS ARE TELL
GOD THE CUBS YOU AND FLAT
STANDARDS AND BOW AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS USING GENERAL
FUND FALLACY I REPRESENTED.
WILL BE MY AREA WE STRONGLY ON
AC A FIGHT PLEASE HOLD STILL.
NINE THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THREE FOUR ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAYBE A LINE THAN ME
LINE THREE FORTY ONE. NINE TWO
TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWO
TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOUR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. MY NAME'S TINA I'M
THRILLED SOUTH CALIFORNIA I
ONLY UPLOAD EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE
NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE NINETY FIVE MAYBE YOUR
pNAME IS AVAILABLE I REGRET LAND
TRIED BALLY MARCH GROUP OF ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MEMBERS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE ACA FIGHT THANK
YOU. LINE THREE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
KATHLEEN THEN- FROM ACADIA- AND
SO I'M VERY APPROACH EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
THREE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THREE SEVEN FULLER PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS THE
LEADING A GRAND NOW I AM FROM
BONITA SCHOOL DISTRICT IT'S
GREAT HM OUR FAMILY WILL. I
DON'T APPROACH EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE IS STILL UNDER. NINE FOUR
OH TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL HELLO
WHO'S FOLLOW ALL YOUR. MINE FOR
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
ONE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES WE
ARE OPEN UNTIL MONDAY THE JONES
WHO WE ARE FAMILY WE'VE
GOVERNMENTAL WE ARE YOUNG AND A
COLD EIGHTY A FINE THAT THE
TOTAL IT. THANK YOU LINE THREE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE FIVE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME WITH THE MY I'M
FROM THE LA I'LL POST IT THE A.
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT ONE SIX EIGHT THE NUMBER
LINE IS OPEN. I ONLY WANT THEM
LATER NINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
MAYBE AIRLINES I'M YOU. YEAH
PERFECT. THE. ONE MOMENT
TERMINATE LINE. ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN ONE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT THE TERM IN. THE LIST Q.
THE LINE FOR FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FOR ONE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M A LEAKY I'M
STRONGER HOLDEN EIGHT THREE
EIGHT FIVE ON BEHALF OF ALL OF.
STILL THERE MA'AM WOMAN. THEN
FOR FOURTEEN GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES MA'AM BUT
YOU WANT TO OPEN. YOU I'M
MAKING SO I'M STRONGLY OPPOSING
A FOR A FLAT ON BEHALF OF ALL
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON OUR OFFICIAL
P. T. HE ON CHANGE .COM
ORGANIZED BY SILICON VALLEY
CHINESE AWFUL FATE HE
FOUNDATION. THANK THANK YOU IN
LINE FOR FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOUR ONE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GRAYSON FROM CAPTAIN TEN
EVERY DAY ENDING ON THAT MY
DADDY EIGHTEEN OF THOSE ANCIENT
WAYS. ARE PUTTING. A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND HOLD ON NEXT
DOOR 83% OF PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY
NO TO ANYTHING FIGHT BUT IN.
YOUR COUNTRY ARE CONTINUING.
LINE FOR SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR ONE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME YEAH HI CAN
FROM SAN DIEGO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE I. SH. LINE. THREE
SEVENTY THREE SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL YES MY NAME IS VERONICA
AND REPRESENT IT THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THAT THE H. WOULD
HAVE REGULAR- THOUSAND FIVE.
OUR EIGHT. NOT EIGHT. THANK.
LINE FOR TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THE ONE THING FROM SAN DIEGO
JOHNNY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
THANK YOU. YOU NEW. LINE FOR
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD FOUR TWO FOUR.
HI YEAH ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
MA'AM. OKAY MY NAME TO CARE
ABOUT LEADING SENATE CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING HE- OPPOSED
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE FOUR OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD FEDERAL FIVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS BEING DROPPED FROM
MOUNTAIN HOUSE CALIFORNIA-
THOUGHT WE PRETEND YOU SEE LA
HAVEN'T GROUP. YOU ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE. ONE FOUR TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SOPHIA LEO I'M CALLING FROM ONE
OF THE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
REPRESENTING YOU SEE AS THE
PARENT GROUP AND I AM- STRONGLY
OPPOSING- ACA FIVE AND THIS
WILL AFFECT. ONE FOUR TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HE DIDN'T THE LATE I
DâN CHINESE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IS HE A FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE FOR TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS FROM A SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AC FIVE THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING MY
NAME IS PENG MADE HANG AND I
REPRESENT EIGHT OF ALL RIGHT
ORGANIZATION IN CALIFORNIA-
COUNTRY FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
I STRONGLY SUPPORT. BY THANK
YOU. IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF ACA FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
LINE FOR TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JEAN HE-
CLICK HERE RIGHT AGAIN AND THE
FATHER OF TWO DAUGHTERS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE THE
CARD IS. NOT NEEDED TO BE ON
THE RESULT IN WRITING RATHER
THANK YOU AND I. AM IN. WE'RE
STILL TAKING NAY ORGANISER AND
POSITION PLEASE. ONE MOMENT FOR
NEXT LINE. WE'RE NOT LINE FOR.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I YES MA'AM IF YOU WE
CAN HEAR YOU. I THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS DANNY I'M FROM
SUNNYVALE AND JOHNNY AND HELD
EIGHTY EIGHT BY THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR THREE FOUR THE LINE IS
OPEN FOR THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I AM DUCK CHAIR
ALL AGREE UNMERITED ASSOCIATION
OUR SALAS SADDAM CARILLO CITY
THEN. OF COURSE AS A FIVE IS
THE DISCRIMINATION. BACK TO TOP.
LINE THREE SEVENTY ONE IT
OPENED THREE SEVEN ZERO BUT.
EMAIL ME THE BILL I MEAN DO YOU
HAVE BEEN THERE- YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MAY NEVER ON MAKING. LINE
FOR THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RITA FROM- SAN JOSE WHY
SOME SAY. I OUR RECORDS AND
CHINESE AMERICANS AND I WANTED
TO STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AC A BY.
THANK YOU. IN ONE MOMENT THE
TERM IN. LINE FOR THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR IT THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND FOR THIRTY ONE
CLICK YOUR GUN SO LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD
SEVEN ZERO. PLAYING TELEPHONE
BIGGER TV I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION IF I. LINE THREE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE EIGHT FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI THE YOUNG FROM THREE
MONTHS I THAT THE BOMB
THOUSANDS OF ASIAN FAMILY IN
OUR COMMUNITY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. THANK
YOU IN THE NEXT LINE ONE ONE
ZERO PLEASE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS TO TELL Mà FROM
SACRAMENTO STRONG OPPOSE EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. IN LINE
FOR SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOR ONE SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STUDENT LOAN ANDI STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. LINE
TWO EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO EIGHT TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I UPDATED CREEK
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL LOAN UNDER
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. LINE. FOUR ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FOR ALL SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO EVERYONE
MACY'S ANY PRIOR A IDEA CORRECT
THEN- WHAT ONE SELDOM AGENT
BANG IT PROPERLY AGAIN IT'S A
GREAT FIVE THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
THEIR EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
MY HI MY NAME IN THE COLDER SAM
CALLING FROM LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
IN JOINING HUNDREDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL TO VOTER.
AGAIN WE ARE IN THE OPPOSITION
PORTION OF ACA FIVES DISCUSSION
AND WE ARE ALSO CONFINING OUR
COMMENTS TO NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. LINE THREE NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THREE NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAYBEOUR LINE THAN
ME DOING ANY ONE. IN THE PLAY
THE DISCONNECT THE LINE TO
FORTY TWO ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LINDA SHOP FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND THREE
OTHER WORKING FAMILIES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE EASIEST SITE
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE ALLOWING
ME YES I DON'T KNOW WHEN. OKAY
THANK YOU THIS IS CONNIE BY
FORMAL- SUNNYVALE- I REPRESENT
TO ESTIMATE THE A AND- THOSE-
SIGNERS FROM THE ONLINE
PETITION THOSE WITH EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. AND
WHAT THIRTY. FATHER AND
SIGNATURE BECAUSE DATE SO
DONNIE UP TO A FIVE YOU TO.
THANK YOU ONE FIFTY THREE
SECURE LINE IS OLD ONE FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE A LINE
THEN YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY SIX.
ONE FOUR FOUR THREE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE FOR FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. YEAH THIS IS THAT
ARLINGTON ACCORDING FROM
EASTERN ATTY COMMUNITIES
LOCATION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE. NINE THREE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE FIVE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO IT'S ME IT YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YEAH MY NAME WEARING
A LONG ONE USED FOR- WARM NON
ASIAN COMMUNITY OUR WEIGHT SO
I'LL ALL POLL. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR FORTY
ONE. ALL RIGHTS MEN FROM
DIAMOND BALL I REPRESENT MANY
FAMILIES OF VARIOUS ETHNICITIES
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE YOU SEE
A FIVE. NINE THREE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS MIKE FROM FREMONT I'M A
STUDENT WHO'S FUTURE WILL BE
HEARD BY A CA FIVE BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE TO CORRECT RIGHT.
LINE FOR THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE FOR THREE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO TO ME
YES THAT YOU PLEASE GOING. ON
UNDER THE VICHY FROM SAN DIEGO
I WOULD CONSIDER MY WHOLE
FAMILY TO STRONGLY OPPOSE. BY
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
WHERE I AM AND ASIAN AMERICAN
MOM- LIVING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE. LINE
FOR FORTY EIGHT IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE LINE FOR
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME SEVEN JERRY JALA AND
MARK SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE AND-
CHAIRMAN OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION AND ASIAN STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION RECRUITMENT TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS. TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. LINE FOR TWENTY NINE THE
LINE IS OPEN LINE FOR TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAY BE
ALIGNED AND MUTE FOR TWENTY
NINE. NINE THREE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS TOM LIMóN SAN DIEGO
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL REPRESENTING
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND UNION
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE CA FIVE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIVE.
THAT'S ONE ZERO. IN OPPOSITION
OF ACA FIVE. GERMAN LINE FOR
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M JUSTIN
LONG YOUR ENGINE THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ME AND I IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. LINE FOR FIFTY FOUR
FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LEVI DRAWL- I AM CALLING FROM
SAN DIEGO AND I REPRESENT A
LOCAL SCHOOL. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. LINE. FOR FIFTY FIVE FOUR
FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU HEAR ME
YES MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU. YEAH
MY NAME IS A HOLY WAR I'M
CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO I
REPRESENT- MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO THE MOM. IN
SAN DIEGO WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR SIXTY ONE FOUR SIX ONE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO I'M IN THE CHAIR OVER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THEIR
GRAD AND I SHARE WE HAD TO STOP
AND MELENDEZ THE DALAI ABOUT.
FIVE ONE FOUR FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DON DIRE CALLING
FROM VENTURA CALIFORNIA I'M A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND A
MEMBER OF THE NOVEL NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS AND I'M CALLING TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA FIVE. ONE
FOUR SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ISSUING
A FROM WHICH BRANCH SAN DIEGO I
RECORD AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY MOM
GREW. WHAT CREATED INCOME FROM
CHILD AND THERE ARE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED MEMBERS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. NINE
FOUR SIXTY THREE THE LINE IS
OPEN FOR SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE THREE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THREE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MADE THESE NOTHING
DOWN ON SAMBA WE ARE STRONGLY
IN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. ONE
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
LOAN. AND STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ONE ONE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE FINDING THE
OVER THE AGE OF PETITIONS
CHANGED ALL. LINE THIRTY
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAYBE A LINE THEN YOU'D LINE
THREE SEVENTEEN. ONE THREE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB ON
THE WAY I'M CALLING FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OTHER
PROGRAMS. ARE NINE ZERO SMALL
BREEDERS ASSOCIATION ARMS WE
STORY. HOMES IS A FIVE. THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME DOUBLE BECAUSE JOHN-
PROBOSCIS CITY CALIFORNIA I WAS
TO BE KIANA BE HAVE CRIED. ALL
THE LESS DON'T. RAINY AT THE
MOMENT. I'M ON MODERN VINEYARD
CUT THAT CALL HOME PLEASE CALL
WE THAT YOU CAN YOUR LINE. HE
MODERATOR. WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY
MORE CALM FOR THE COUPLE SO IF
YOU. I MEAN. MODERATOR CUT THAT
PERSON OFF. AND WE'RE GONNA
TAKE FIVE MORE MINUTES I THINK
WE HAVE TWENTY PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT MODERATOR HOW MANY
PEOPLE YES SIR THAT IS CORRECT
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE FINAL
TWENTY TWENTY MINUTES I. THIS
SO IF YOU COULD TAKE THAT
MODERATOR OFF. THAT PERSON WHO
SHOULDN'T BE ON WE HAVE TWENTY
MORE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THOSE TWENTY PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
MEMBERS COMMENTS- WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S- WAITING IN ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE FINAL TWENTY
PEOPLE AND THEN MOVE TO MEMBERS
COMMENTS THANK YOU. ONE OUR
COALITION AND GETTING ARMED
SADDAM IT. RIGHT EIGHT.
ACTUALLY IT WAS. THE ROCK. IF
WE- ARE A RARE. WE'LL TAKE
THOSE FINAL FINAL TWENTY PEOPLE
ON THIS AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO MEMBERS COMMENTS THANK
YOU. ONE AND- LINE FOR FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR FIVE
ONE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAYBE
YOU'RE ON MEANING RIGHT. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO. TO FOUR FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN ZERO. FOUR
SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO RESPONSE
WILL BE LEAVING YEAH LINE FOR
SEVENTY ONE. WHAT THANK YOU IN
LINE. FOR SEVENTY ONE ON THE
LINE IS OPEN FOR SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NOW. HELLO GIVEN
THAT YOU WOULD GO AHEAD. YEAH
MY NAME ZERO TURN FROM SALEM
ôNG. OKAY FIVE ON BEHALF OF MY
NEIGHBORHOOD OKAY SEVENTY
PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. ARE YOU KNOW I. AND HE
OKAY. ONE MOMENT NOT IT'S A LOT.
YEAH. THE ONLY ARE NOT. ONE
MOMENT ALLEN THE WHOLE YOU'RE
REALLY. YEAH RIGHT. ONE MOMENT
THE CHAIR. THANK YOU WILL BE
GOING TO THE LINE OF FOUR
SEVENTY SIX ONE FOUR SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE FOUR
SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU.
WITH NO RESPONSE WE'LL GO ON TO
ONE FOR SIXTY TWO FOR THINGS TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN THE EMAIL FROM LAKE
FOREST ABOUT POSE EIGHTY FIVE
STRONGLY BECAUSE EIGHTY TERROR
JUST THREE. LINE FR SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS ALICIA KEEN
I REPRESENT VERY- LOTS OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT AIN'T THAT A
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THREE EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU IT. ONE FOUR
EIGHT ZERO FOUR A. B. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME IS
HOME SURE I'M REPRESENTING MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE EACH
AREA YELLOWCAKE TO RECTIFY
ASIAN I'M NOT. ANYTHING
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE PLEASE WELL NO THANK
YOU. LINE FOUR EIGHTY SIX. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOUR EIGHTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
THE WAY I AM LED UP TO KEEP IN
SACRAMENTO I PRESENT MY FAMILY
AND I'M NOT HELP MY FRIEND I
HAVE KEEPING TEMPERAMENTAL
WE'LL ALL GO ONLY A CODE. EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE NEEDS MULLIN NOW
THANK. NINE FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS FILLING MEAL
FROM HEY WHAT I'M LANDING MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED FAMILIES IN
HEY WHAT MADE OF COKE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED A FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FOUR EIGHT SEVEN.
I'M YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN HUNDRED THE WHOLE
PROBLEM THE HOME TO WORKING
KOREAN STUDENTS WHICH JOHNNY UP
HOLDEN AGE EIGHTY FIVE. THANK
YOU LINE FOR NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE FOR NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WILL GO ON TWO ONE
FOUR NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
CALL HELP MEND IT HELLO MY NAME
IS DARLENE I'M CALLING FROM ALL
DIRECTIONS. MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND AND TRY OF ASIAN
AMERICAN APPARENT HEARING
INVALIDATED ALL WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED. BY. FIVE OH TWO NINE
FIVE ZERO TWO ZERO ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
MORNING THIS IS CHEN GEN CON
FROM SAN JOSE I WILL PRESENT A
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED NEIGHBORS
IN NINE FIVE ONE TWO FOUR WE
STRONGLY AGAINST THE ACB HI
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M ON
FOUR NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MINE FOR
NINETY THREE MAY BE ALIGNED ON
MUTE. ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR. WE
ARE NOT IN LINE FIVE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIVE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SHERRY I'M IN NINTH GRADE
FROM FREMONT I STRONGLY OPPOSED
THE EIGHTY FIVE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE ZERO FIVE FIVE ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS EILEEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AC A FIVE ON THE HOT.
OFF ON. PRESENTING OTHER THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE STRONGLY UP
HOLDS A CA FIVE A PLEASE VOTED
NO ON A CA FIVE. THANK YOU IN.
IN OUR FINAL LINE WILL COME
FROM. ONE MOMENT THE CHAIRMAN.
LINE FOR NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD FOR
NINETY EIGHT. MAYBE ALIGNED ON
MUTE. LINE FOR NINETY EIGHT.
WITH NO RESPONSE THE CHAIRMAN
YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK YOU-
MADAME MODERATOR APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP- DURING THAT- PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I ALSO WANT TO
APPRECIATE TO EVERYONE WHO
SPOKE BOTH FOR AND AGAINST- ACA
FIVE IT WAS PARTICULARLY- NICE
TO HEAR SO MANY YOUNG VOICES
GETTING INVOLVED IN THE CIVIC
DISCOURSE. AND SO THAT'S
APPRECIATED AND FOR THE MOST
PART EVERYONE WAS VERY CIVIL IN
THEIR COMMENTS WHICH IS ALSO
APPRECIATED ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. OR COMMENTS
AT THIS POINT TWO OR DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. MISTER BRADFORD YOU
WANNA MAKE A COMMONER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'VE WITH FIRST
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO CALLED IN AND SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. BUT I'M- I WAS LEFT
WITH SOME CONCERN THAT ANYONE
WOULD VIEW THIS. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS RACES- IF ANYONE
KNOWS THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY WE'VE HAD FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS. OF DECISIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE BASED ON RACE AND
TO. ELIMINATE WHAT PROP. TOOL
NINE CREATED IN. A LIMITING
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES OF ANY BY DOESN'T
THINK THAT SAID A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA- DO YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN HERE LONG STILL-
THIS IS LEVELING THE PLAYING
FIELD. I STRONGLY SUPPORTED
BECAUSE EVERY YEARS SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE
NIBBLED AROUND THE EDGES OF
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESS MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESS OR HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE. AT PRIME EXAMPLE IS SB
ONE WHEN WE INJECTED LANGUAGE
FOR. MINORITY CONTRACTORS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR SO WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO
LEGISLATURE LIKE THAT AN INSERT
LANGUAGE LIKE THIS A TOOL NINE
WAS REMOVED SO ON THAT NOTE I'D
LOOK TOWARDS AND ASK FOR A VOTE
ON. AND THAT'S A MOTION. IN A
MOTOR FOR SUPPORT EXACTLY
AWESOME AND BEFORE WE GO TO A
MISTER WHITE CASTLE. MR
CHERISHES I NOTE THAT THE STAFF
COMMENTS- SAYING FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE THAT THAT
THIS CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
WILL COST ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PAGE. AND I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS THAT THAT'S THE
STANDARD FOR ANYTHING THAT
APPEARS IN THIS NOVEMBER BALLOT
IS EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
WHICH IS THE FISCAL EFFECT OF
THIS ALTHOUGH THE OPPOSITION
RAISE SOME. IN ON SOME COSTS OF
DEVALUING EDUCATION AND
UNNECESSARY IS THAT THE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS A
THE STANDARD COST PER PAGE FOR
ANYTHING THAT'S GOING TO BE ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT. YES THAT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIS BALLOT MEASURE THAN ANY
OTHER BALLOT MEASURE AND
NORMALLY WHAT AS WE SIT HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WERE LIST LOOKING AT THE FISCAL
COST TO THE STATE RATHER THAN
SOME EXTRAPOLATION OF WHAT WE
THINK. GENERATIONS DOWN THE
LINE WILL COST ON THE SOCIETY
AS A WHOLE CORRECT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE HARD COSTS OF
THIS BILL BEING ON THE BALLOT.
AND THAT COSTS REFLECTS THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
I SHOULD ALSO NOTE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS MEASURE NOR
DID IT HAVE A FILE ON THE PRIOR
MEASURE. ORDERS THAT HAVE A
FILE ON THE SUCCEEDING MEASURE
SO FOR THE RECORD- WE KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. I DO WANT TO MAKE
ONE COMMENT TO MISTER BRADFORD
MISSED BRADFORD UNIT I'VE
SERVED FOR A LONG TIME. AND I
HAVE TO GIVE YOU SIGNIFICANT
PROPS BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE TIME
INITIATIVE A PROPOSAL HAS COME
UP. FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
YOU ABOUT A CONSISTENT MESSAGE
AND HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A- STRONG
ADVOCATE OF HOW THAT
PARTICULAR. INITIATIVE AFFECTS
PEOPLE OF COLOR UNDER
REPRESENTED BUSINESSES BOTH
AND- BOTH UNDER REPRESENTED
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WOMEN AND
YOU'VE BEEN ON THAT MESSAGE FOR
AS LONG AS I'VE KNOWN YOU. HAVE
BEEN A CONSISTENT STRONG VOICE
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THOSE
APPROPRIATE COMMENTS TODAY. MS
WEBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES FIRST OF ALL WHEN I THINK-
OBVIOUSLY THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS DURING THIS OF.
HEARING AND APPRECIATE ALL
THOSE WHO TOOK THE TIME TO CALL
IN BECAUSE- THAT'S WHAT
DEMOCRACY IS ALL ABOUT AND WE
HOPE WE WILL CONTINUE THAT. BY
APPROVING A CA FIVE THAT WILL
DIDN'T GIVE THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEADERS OPPORTUNITIES TO DESIGN
AND REDESIGN PLANS AND PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES. THAT CAN BENEFIT
CAL CALIFORNIANS GIVING A
HELPING US TO OVERCOME THE BIAS
THAT WE NORMALLY HAVE IN TERMS
OF HISTORY BY SOME EXCLUSION OF
INDIVIDUALS. FROM THE OF NOT
ONLY THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM BUT
ALSO FROM EMPLOYMENT AS WELL AS
CONTRACTING THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE SAID MOST OF
US. AND IT IS IT IS IT ONLY
FITTING THAT WE ALLOW AFTER
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF THE PUBLIC
TO MAKE A DECISION BECAUSE
THEY'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE. WHAT IS HAPPENING TWENTY
FOUR YEARS IN CALIFORNIA AND DO
WE WANT TO STAY OUT OF THE OF
THE BILL IS OF EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS. OR DO
YOU WANT TO GET IN LINE WITH
THE OTHER. STATES OTHER FORTY
TWO STATES IT ACTUALLY A HOPPER
FROM BACK. AND AGGRESSIVE%
EFFORTS TO TRY TO KEEP. CREATE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY IN ACCESS
SOMEONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL HAS VERY
LITTLE COSTS OTHER THAN.
PUTTING IT ON THE BALLOT- BUT I
THINK IN THE LONG RUN WE WILL
SEE THE BENEFIT OF IT IN TERMS
OF WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
ABILITY TO DO. AND ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO PARTICIPATE IN
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISS WHOEVER FOR
BREAKING THIS PHONE THE CHAIRS
RECORD. IS A DO. TO THE SENATE
FOR. MISTER WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEASURE ACA FOR
THE MOTION IS BE A TOP IN REFER
TO THE SAN FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO FIVE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD HI.
BRADFORD BY HILL. HI HILL I
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY CAO SKI HI MAKOWSKI. IT'S
FIVE TWO THE BILL THE ACA IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF FIVE TO THE
SENATE FOR MEMBERS AND THOSE
FOLKS WAITING IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU MS WEBER
CONGRADULATIONS- THOSE FOLKS
WAITING IN THE QUEUE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE SHORT-
BREAK WE'LL BE BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES- SO THE COMMITTEE WILL
RECESS FOR FIVE MINUTES.
WE ARE
GOING TO GO BACK. TO OUR SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAVE ONE ITEM LEFT
MR MCCARTY IS A CA SIX AND SO
MISTER MCCARTY WE HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS HERE TO START MYSTIC
MCCARTY PLEASE TELL US ABOUT A
CA SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF COURSE THIS IS THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO AWFUL BECAUSE ON
THAT WON'T RE HASH THE POLICY
WHICH WE DID A COUPLE DAYS AGO
IN THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
THIS MEASURE A CA SIX WOULD PUT
ON THE BALLOT A PROPOSAL TO LET
THE PEOPLE ENGAGE ON WHO SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FIVE YEARS
AGO. IS ANOTHER MEASURE.
DIRECTED VOTING RIGHTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE. AND THIS
WOULD. RIGHT THAT WRONG AND
ADDRESS THE CONFUSION ABOUT WHO
CAN VOTE. OF COURSE PEOPLE ON
PROBATION CAN VOTE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON PAROLE CANNOT VOTE WHEN
THEY'RE- ON THEIR PEARL TERM.
AND THIS CREATES A LOT OF
ISSUES OUT THERE NOT TO
MENTION. I DISENFRANCHISES OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE. IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
WE'VE HAD. RED STATES AND BLUE
STATES. UP THIS. REFORM ARE
BEFORE US TODAY ARE OF COURSE
ONE TIME- FUNDS A SOCIALLY
WOULD PUT THIS MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY I
HAVE ONE WITNESS FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY YES I BELIEVE WE HAVE.
REPRESENTATIVE THE SECOND
SECRETARY STATES OFFICE AS OUR
PRIMARY. WITNESSES SUPPORT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO CAN FIND YOUR-
TESTIMONY TO THREE MINUTES WE
WILL THEN BE GOING TO. THE
CHAMBERS TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
AND THEN ONLINE SO PLEASE.
SHARE YOUR PERSPECTIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS YOU SOMEONE TO LONG
GOING BEHIND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE THE END STRONG OF. EIGHTY
SIX THE PLEASURE IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE OUR STANDARD BALLOT
MEASURE PRODUCT COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THAT THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF OUT MEASURES
ENACTED AFTER THE DEADLINE.
BUDGET ALLOCATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. SIX SIX
TESTIMONY- ANYBODY IN THE
RAFTERS THAT WANTS TO COME OUT
THAT WAS YOUR ONLY WHEN HIS
RIGHT WRIST MCCARTY. ALL RIGHT
NO ONE IN THE RAFTERS IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
IT DOES NOT APPEAR SO MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP WE ARE
TAKING SUPPORT. FOR A CA FIVE
IN THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE
LISTENING AT HOME- THIS IS THE
SUPPORT FOR A CA FIVE POSITION-
AS NOTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS MEASURE. AND IF YOU COULD
CONFINE YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. THE CHECK IN DESK
CONFIRMING THAT IT EIGHTY SIX
CORRECT I'M SORRY CA SIX YOU
ARE CORRECT. AC AC SLATER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIX ONLY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER IN PLACE
YOU BACKING Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX ONLY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. LINE
FIVE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEWMAN
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU SIR. HI MY
NAME IS MICHAEL CARL ON THE
CHANNEL OR KNOWS ABOUT WAS
ASKING LOCAL CHURCH AND NINE
INCHES AND WEBER ALONG WITH AN
GOING OF CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AGES SIX.
THANK YOU IN LINE FIVE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON- MY
NAME IS MARIA GOMEZ SIDE
CALLING- FROM SATURDAY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS EASY A SIX.
THANK YOU AND LINE FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS CAITLYN DEAN FROM THE
ALLIANCE THE BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK. NINE FIVE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FINE FINE. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU I. PERFECT THANK
YOU DUST ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND CITY AND
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN COURT
AT EIGHT EIGHT SIX THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN ONE SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AGAIN THAT
KALINOWSKI EIGHT TELL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF AJ SIX THANK YOU. NINE TO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO THIRTY
FIVE. NINE FIVE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME THE LEAH
REYNOLDS AND UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC SANTA BARBARA AND
THE EXTERNAL BY PRESENT
STATEWIDE AFFAIRS THERE FOR AT
THE STATE YEAH AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG STRONG WORD OF EIGHT
EIGHT THAT. MINE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY EVERYONE. ONE
MOMENT ONE FORTY NINE. GO AHEAD
SIR. RIGHT WHEN POSH ON
COVERAGE DURING TO YOU IF YOU
MISS OSSETIAN ON THE APPLE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND ARE YOU CAN BECAUSE YOU ARE
STRONG BOB IF YOU TAKE A LITTLE
CLICHE- ARE LOOKING KILEY OR
INFORM THE STATE THANK. THANK
YOU NINE ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE ONE SIX SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN YOUR LEGAL
WOMEN VOTERS THE CALIFORNIA-
THE CLIP ONTO THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIFTY EIGHT MAYBE YOU'RE
ON MUTE. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
MA'AM. MANY TWENTY CHANCE- I'M
NOT. THE I WHAT DO YOU DO
CREATION I DON'T CALL FOR
STRONG SUPPORT ACA. SIX THANK
YOU AND ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIVE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. QUESTION
ANSWER ON BEHALF OF MARK AT THE
CALIFORNIA AND DRUNK THE PORT
OF EIGHTY EIGHT THANK. NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TO NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT NEW YEAR'S DAY POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CUT. PROUD
COSPONSORED IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AJ SIX. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR
TURN MEMBERS- SOMETHING THREE
ON BEHALF OF YOU A W. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE REPRESENTING%
ACADEMIC STUDENT EMPLOYEES THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF EACH YEAR THANK.
NINE ONE NINETY THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETY THREE MAY BE ALIGNED ON
ME. ONE TO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MEMBERS AARON LEVIN BOND
BEHALF OF NAY ROB PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND THE PART. NINE
FIVE SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIVE
SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YES
MA'AM WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
AREN'T MANY TESCO AGAIN I'M
WITH URBAN SCHOOLS AND THE
DISCO AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SIX. NINE FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HOLLY DO WE I'M A STUDENT AND
THE CHIEF OF STAFF IN THE
OFFICE OF THE EXTERNAL VICE
PRESIDENT OF STATE RIGHT
AFFAIRS THAT YOU CAN A BARBARA
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. YOU SEE ANYTHING.
THANK YOU. NINE SIX ZERO TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF SECURE
DEMOCRACY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE MAYBE YOUR ON MUTE.
ARE YOU THERE. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY HI MY NAME THE MORROW
WILL THEN I'M CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES AND WE ATE A LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND YES I'M
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK. THANK YOU.
NINE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO ALL EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHAEL EIGHT MAY BE ON
MUTE. ONE FOUR FIFTY ONE ONE OF
THE OPEN FOR FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ABOUT MENTAL I'M FROM YOUTH
YOUTH AND A BARBER I THIRD YEAR
I AM FOUNDER OF DOCTORS ARE
TRANSPARENCY I'M THE
COMMUNICATION DIRECTORS GROW
EXTERNALIZE PRESIDENT
STATEWIDE. I AM THE
COMMUNICATIONS REPUBLICAN CP
COMMISSION OF ISLA VISTA AND
I'M IN ALSO CORPS OF ACT AND
SIX. NINE SIX HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JON MECHANICAL AND I
REPRESENT BLACK AND ASIAN
GRANDPARENTS FOR EQUITY I'M
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF. EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN BY
THREE ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS TIENE OF ARGUS ADMIN
WITH INITIATE JUSTICE BRONCOS
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT IN
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS COURTNEY RIDE IN A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER AND COULDN'T
EDUCATOR ON BEHALF OF MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE AND INCARCERATED
PEOPLE WE FOR COURT. EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX. MINE SIX ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SIX ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GRAY RAINING
CABRIOLET WELL WUNDERMAN
UNDERGRADUATE YOU CAN KIND OF
BARBARA I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
MINE SIX TWELVE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. NINE SIX
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I AM. FROM YOU CAN A
GIRL I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ATHEISTIC. MINE SIX THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI SEVEN MEN CAN WITH
POINTED FOR PROGRESS WE HAVE A
PRIORITY SUPPORT POSITION ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX. NINE FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD.HI MARK AND I
AM OF FORMER HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AND RESIDENT OKAY THIS
GIRL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA.
NINE SIX ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEFF
THE HUGE SUPPORT IF YOU EXPECTS.
LINE SIX SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
RELIABLE BY OTHER. THE ASSEMBLY
NECK HEALTHY STATE DIRECTOR.
I'M SORRY YOUR DEADLINE GOING
IN AND OUT. ONE MOMENT THE
GERMAN. ONE MOMENT WE'RE HAVING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX THREE TWO UP
WITH ONE ZERO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF A THREE ONE
SIX. EACH PRESS ONE DIDN'T ZERO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ONE
MOMENT LINE SIX ONE FIVE ONE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MANY
MENTAL JOHN MY HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER- AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE CA SEXTING HERE.
THANK YOU LINE FOR ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JUST AYE WILLIAMS
A. B. O. S. BAY AREA IF YOU ASK
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF A CD
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
ONE NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS ERIC HARRIS OF THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA SIX.
THANK YOU ONE TWO OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY TO EIGHT MAYBE ON MUTE. WE
WANT TO LINE SIX HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES MA'AM YOU'RE GONNA GO
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M SORRY-
BUT THIS IS JEAN RIGHT I AM A
PSYCHOTHERAPIST AND I'M FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ACA'S SEX
THANK YOU. LINE SIX TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GRACIE
VEGA I AM A RESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M CALLING IN
FOR MY STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO OKAY. MY
NAME IS RON I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
WHERE THEIR BECAUSE GO AND I'M
CALLING IN BOTH SUPPORT OF IT.
NINE SIX FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS WAITING YEAH I FROM
SACRAMENTO EVER PRESENT GRAY
WHAT CHIANG WHO AND I'M ALSO
WILL FOR CALIFORNIA STATE AND
HOW CAN. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT RIGHT BECAUSE
EIGHT. WE ARE ON. FORTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT SIX ACA FIVE
HAS ALREADY BEEN DISPENSED WITH
FROM THE COMMITTEE SO IF YOU'RE
ONLINE FOR A CA FIVE YOU MISSED
THAT ONE THIS IS A CA SIX AND
IT IS THE SUPPORT FOR A CA SIX
OF YOU HERE FOR SB FOR TEN
FOURTEEN TEN OR AC A FIVE THOSE
BOTH HAVE PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE. AND ARE HEADED TO
THE FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IN LINE SIX TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HOOKED
UP OF A GUY WITH ME FOR MEDIA
WHAT THEFRESNO A MAN I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER.
EIGHTY SIX. AND AT THIS TIME OF
THE TERM AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB CA SIX.
BUDGET LIKE ME TO REVIEW NO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MODERATOR WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON TO. THE OPPOSITION OF A
CA SIX I DO NOT BELIEVE. THERE
IS A- PRIMARY. SPEAKER FOR A CA
SIX SO WE'RE GOING TO GO RIGHT
TO THE SENATE CHAMBER. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION OF A CA
SIX WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OR NOT SEE ANYBODY. IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO WE WILL
THEN GO TO OUR PHONE LINE. AND
SO THIS AGAIN FOR EVERYONE
LISTENING. SB FOR TEN HAS
ALREADY PASSED THIS BODY. AN
ACA FIVE HAS ALREADY PASSED
WITH THIS BODY OUR FINAL PIECE
OF BUSINESS IS A CA SIX WE HAVE
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORTERS. AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE OPPOSITION TO A CA SIX. AND
IF YOU COULD CONFINE YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT SO WITH
THAT MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP UP
PEOPLE FOR OPPOSITION TO A CA
SIX. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
A THREE EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AND THE OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER
IN PLACE YOU BACKING Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF A CA ONE. FOUR
EIGHT EIGHT SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. HEY
MISTER CHAIRMAN LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
MAY BE ON MUTE I CAN HEAR YOU
IF ANY. IT YES THANK YOU AND WE
CAN HEAR YOU YEAH OKAY I
STRONGLY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE ONE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE SIX ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
NUMBER THAT DISTANCE NEED CREEL
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA I'M- I HAD A Q.
ISSUE SO I'M SORRY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE- THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FIVE FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE A
LINE THEN YOU FIVE FORTY. LINE
TWO THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TO THIRTY FIVE MAYBE
YOUR LINES ON MUTE. IN ONE
MOMENT THE TERM AND WE DO HAVE
ONE LAST PERSON WE'RE TRYING TO
GET A MY NUMBER NOW. AND AT THE
TIME OF DETERMINE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT- THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
PORTION. OF THIS HEARING WE'VE
HEARD BOTH FROM THE PROPONENTS
AND THE OPPONENTS WE HAVE NO
FILE ON THIS MATTER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTER
BRADFORD I SAW YOUR MICROPHONE
GO UP. YOU WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT I JUST SIT APPROPRIATE
TIME I WILL LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION ON THIS MEASURE A CA SIX
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS.
HARD WORK AND I THINK. ALLOWING
THOSE FOLKS WHO HAVE PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY TO PARTICIPATE
ONCE AGAIN A TO THE- BAA
PROCESS OF NOT ONLY REGISTERING
TO VOTE. AND VOTING. IS THE
TRUE WAY OF DEMOCRACY AND ALONG
THESE FOLKS VICES TO BE HEARD
IN RE ENGAGE THEM BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY SO THEY CAN BE
POSITIVE CONTRIBUTORS TO
COMMUNITY AND- REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AS WELL SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER BRADFORD AND
FOR YOUR MOTION SEEING NO OTHER
HANDS GO UP. MR MCCARTY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU AS
AS MISTER BRADFORD SAID
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THIS
ACTUALLY HELPS WITH RECIDIVISM
SALT IS CLOSE BY SAYING THIS IS
GOOD FOR DEMOCRACY. AND THIS IS
ALSO GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
WITH THAT ASK FOR YOUR IBM
THANK YOU. AND AS A FISCAL
COULD MANY OF WE LOWER THE
RECIDIVISM RATE WE WILL SAVE
MONEY. AS WELL AS HELP PEOPLE'S
LIVES- THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDING
AN AYE VOTE TO MOVE TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. TO REMOTE THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACA SIX THE MOTION IS TO BE
ADOPTED REFERRED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT BATES. BRADFORD OUR
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL I JONES
JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA ON MY
CASKEY HI KELSEA PART. VOTERS
FIVE TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT
pFIVE TO ONE- ALL THERE ARE NO
MEASURES ON CALL THAT CONCLUDES
OUR- HEARING- BUSINESS BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS OBVIOUSLY I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY DUE TO A
TECHNICAL GLITCH. OR FOR SOME
OTHER REASON PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE INCLUDED IN
THE OFFICIAL PUBLIC HEARING
RECORDS SO IF YOU DID NOT FOR
ANY REASON AT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE
DO. IN WRITING WE- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN A NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES WE
HAD YOUNG PEOPLE CALLING IN.
AND THAT'S ALSO KIND OF COOL
FROM THE DATA ME SO I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. AND
WE'VE CONCLUDED ARE SENATE
BUSINESS OF THE APPROPRIATI